I got my COVID booster shot today, I'm feeling a little low from the side effects, but you know what I don't feel low for. I was just in dad hell. It took a deep breath. Yeah, it took a couple deep breaths. Oh my God, I'm all sweaty and my hands are dirty, which is the worst part of it all. Look at the way he holds his hands like a sage. I haven't been able to wash my hands.
我今天打了新冠加强针，副作用让我觉得有点无精打采的，但你们知道为什么我不会无精打采吗。我刚才经历了老爸的噩梦。我深吸了一口气。对，深吸了好几口气。天哪，我满身大汗，手也弄脏了，这才是最糟糕的部分。看他那双手像个圣人一样端着。我到现在还没洗手呢。
Like working on a car. I just got a 150 pound delivery from UPS, which was Maple's new, I'm not a little girl anymore, basketball hoop. Sure. Oh, I have that. Oh God. I just spent the good part of three hours assembling just half of it. I had to, I had to punt and I'm going to have to do the other half tomorrow or after this.
就像在修车一样。我刚刚收到UPS送来的150磅的快递，那是枫叶的新篮球架——我已经不是小女孩了。当然。哦，我也有那个。天哪。我刚刚花了差不多三个小时才组装好了一半。我不得不中场休息，打算明天或者录完节目后再搞定另一半。
And guys, if you ever had an Ikea injury, you know, where you really haven't screwed in a bolt or anything for like maybe ever in your forearms the next day or just ripped to hell, I'm going to have like, this is not Ikea. This is a real big boy hoop. Why not get, why not get one over the, over the garage, like when you just put it on the garage? Well, I'd have to assemble that too, Sean. Oh, like the Cunninghams had on how to do this.
伙计们，如果你们有过宜家工伤，就是那种可能这辈子从没用过螺丝刀拧螺丝，结果第二天前臂酸痛到不行的经历，或者简直快废了，我的手臂就要——这不是宜家。这是一个真正的“大男孩”篮球架。为什么不买个装在车库上的那种，就那种直接挂在车库上的？好吧，肖恩，我也得组装那个。哦，就像《Cunningham一家》里那样。
Yeah. First of all, Ikea, I've always said the Ikea is Swedish for argument because anytime you go into an Ikea store on a weekend, you just see going like, we don't need that. It's so true. Well, we've already got the one in the other room. Oh my God, like doing that. Yeah. We've already got the other thing.
对。首先，宜家，我一直说“宜家”在瑞典语里的意思是“争吵”，因为每逢周末你去宜家逛逛，就会看到有人在说：“我们根本不需要那个。”太真实了。好吧，我们在另一个房间里已经有一个了。天哪，就是那种感觉。对。我们已经有别的东西了。
I really feel proud. There's a certain pride that comes with the finishing of the assembly. For sure. And this one. I always feel a pride when I finish. We're talking about the same thing, right? Yeah. So I'm going to feel like, well, I'm not going to extrapolate on your metaphor there, but
我真的感到很自豪。完成组装的那一刻确实会带来一种成就感。确实。还有这个。我每次完成都会有一种自豪感。我们是在说同一件事吧？对。所以我会有这种感觉——好吧，我就不引申你的那个隐喻了，但是
I'm going to feel so good when this is done, but it's made me late. My hands are dirty and I'm only half done. Again, I think we're talking about the same thing. And almost more importantly, I have not had the time to do my prep for my guest today. Oh, that's okay. Yeah. So your guest. I think this is today.
这事搞定后我会感觉超棒，但它让我迟到了。我的手脏了，而且才干了一半。话说回来，我觉得我们俩说的还是同一件事。更重要的是，几乎同样重要的是，我今天根本没时间为我的嘉宾做准备。哦，没关系。好吧。所以你的嘉宾。我想这就是今天。
This is my guest, I think, right? It is your guest. Yeah, it is. And yeah. And so this is going to be my first raw dog. I've never. Still talking about the same thing. Boy, this is a long subject.
这是我的嘉宾，我想，对吧？是你的嘉宾。对，没错。而且。所以这将是我的第一次“生肉”首秀。我从来没——还在说同一件事。天哪，这个话题可真长。
Now we're talking about a different thing. Wait. First of all, I missed, I missed you guys last night. I was supposed to see you for dinner at a friend's house and I don't know if he was there. Well, I don't know why I didn't make it because I kind of partially, partially pulled my back. You did. And so it's all about old man for me today.
现在我们在说另一件事了。等等。首先，我昨晚想念你们了。我本该去一个朋友家和你们一起吃晚饭的，我不知道他当时在不在。好吧，我不知道自己为什么没去，因为我的背稍微有点拉伤了。你确实拉伤了。所以今天对我来说全都是“老头子”的日常。
That's a thing. But Jason, and then I stopped by Will's house on the way home and I texted you, hey, I'm stopping at Will's if you want to come by. You did. I ignored that text because I was still pissed off at my back. That's all right. And didn't even answer him. No, I don't do that.
确实是这样。但是杰森，后来我在回家的路上顺便去了威尔家，我还给你发了短信：“嘿，我要去威尔家，你要不要顺便过来？”你确实发了。我忽略了那条短信，因为我还在为我的背生闷气。没关系。甚至连回都没回。不，我才不干那种事。
Sometimes. You're such a... Well, it didn't assess it. No, here. Guess what? I read you the goddamn text right now. I don't know how this does not trigger a response at all. Missed you tonight, period.
有时候。你真是个……好吧，当时没看到。不，给。你猜怎么着？我现在就把这该死的短信读给你听。我不知道这怎么就一点反应也没有。错过了今晚，句号。
We left because Scotty's tired, period. Stopping off at Will's to say, quick, hello, if you feel like jaunting over, period. Well, I don't. And thanks for the update. Well, we got it now. 24 hours later, he got it. Hey, speaking of good friends. So Sean did come over last night with Scotty.
我们走了，因为斯科蒂累了，句号。顺便去威尔家打个招呼，如果你想溜达过来，句号。好吧，我不想。谢谢你的最新进展。好吧，我们现在知道了。24小时后，他看到了。嘿，说到好朋友。所以肖恩昨晚确实和斯科蒂一起过来了。
Well, we're saying good friend, it's not like you just got back from the hospital and everyone's got to stop by. Yeah. No, but Will's, your house is spectacular. Oh, thanks, man. It's just very good for you. Unbelievable. Thank you.
好吧，我们说的好朋友，又不是你刚从医院回来，大家非得顺路去探望那种。对。不，不过威尔，你的房子太壮观了。哦，谢谢你，老兄。对你来说真的很棒。简直难以置信。谢谢。
Thank you. It's so beautiful. It's taken a long time. But Jay, I think you're really going to like it. And we're talking about Monday, doing a hang, Chémoire with everybody. Oh, sorry. Listener. Just hold on one second.
谢谢。太漂亮了。花了很长时间。但杰伊，我觉得你一定会喜欢的。我们在说周一的时候，大家一起聚聚，Chez-moi。哦，抱歉。听众朋友。请等一下。
Will decided to take your time to make some plans. What is it, Will? A week from today. What are we doing? Looked at his bid take. By the way, we just talked about you putting together a fucking basketball hoop for your daughter. But that's podcast worthy.
威尔决定花时间做点计划。是什么呀，威尔？从今天起一周后。我们在干嘛？看了看他的日程表。顺便说一句，我们刚才还在聊你给你女儿组装该死的篮球架。但那才叫有播客价值。
I'm not just fucking filling up my file of facts with the next Monday's plans. Just open to fill up your Google news alerts with links about cute dad moment. Jason Bateman put together a fucking basketball. I'm self-effacing right now. I'm talking about how soft I am. I'm texting Amanda right now. I want to get a photo of you putting that together so badly. But all the damage I did to my daughter, I'm trying to do good things for my daughter.
我可不是在用下周一的计划去填满我那些废话档案。你只管用那些关于可爱老爸时刻的链接来塞满你的谷歌新闻提醒。杰森·贝特曼组装了一个该死的篮球架！我现在正表现得很谦逊呢。我正在自我解嘲。我正在给阿曼达发短信呢。我太想拍一张你组装那玩意的照片了。虽然我对女儿造成了伤害，但我正努力为女儿做好事。
And the damage I did yelling at her while I'm putting this thing together, she's asking to help. Do you think by you asking for help that you're helping? By the way, that's a great impression of you. Inflections on the wrong words. All right. Let's get to it. It is.
我在组装这玩意的同时冲她大吼大叫，这对我女儿造成的伤害——她还吵着要帮忙。你觉得你要求帮忙是在帮倒忙吗？顺便说一句，你刚才模仿得太像了。重音都放在了错误的词上。好了。我们开始吧。就是这样。
I love seeing you frazzled. Our guest has a great daughter that I bet he's nicer to than I am to mine. Or at least assembles more things for. So here I am. Just raw dog in it right now. Our guest, I don't have my Wikipedia in front of me, but I should know enough. He, okay. So it's a man.
我最喜欢看你手忙脚乱的样子了。我们的嘉宾有个很棒的女儿，我敢打赌他对女儿肯定比我对我的好。或者至少他组装的东西更多。所以现在，我来了。直接硬着头皮上了。我们的嘉宾，我手头没有维基百科，但我应该了解得差不多。他，好吧。是个男的。
That part I researched. Well, you gave it away a while ago, but go ahead. No, no. Did I really? Yeah. He has a daughter? Yeah. That was earlier.
这部分我做过研究。好吧，你刚才早就泄露了，不过继续吧。不，不。我真的泄露了吗？对。他有个女儿？对。那是在前面。
But anyway, keep going, man. What do you mean I keep going? I don't know who it is, but I know that it's a he because you said he. Okay. So it's a he. Oh my God. He's a father. There we go.
不过总之，继续说吧，老兄。什么叫我继续说？我不知道他是谁，但我知道是个“男的”，因为你用了“他”。好吧。是个“男的”。天哪。他是个父亲。这就对了。
He's an actor. Do you know him? Yeah, man. Okay. And he's great. Okay. He's nice. Okay.
他是个演员。你认识他吗？对，老兄。好吧。而且他很棒。好吧。他很好。好吧。
You want to just say his name and so we can start? No, not yet. He's funny. What time today did you hit fuck it? You just. I spent all I had putting it up. Half the hoop. How's your back now, by the way?
你能不能直接说出他的名字，好让我们开始？不，还不行。他很有趣。你今天是什么时候爆粗口的？你只是——我把我所有的力气都花在组装上了。半个篮球架。对了，你的背现在怎么样了？
And you know what? We're going to, we're going to find out a lot about this guest and we're going to give him a chance to tell us, but I'll tell you what I do know. Yeah. I love him. Okay. And will loves him. Yeah.
你知道吗？我们将要，我们将要了解很多关于这位嘉宾的信息，我们会给他一个机会来告诉我们，但我可以告诉你我所知道的。对。我爱他。好吧。威尔也爱他。对。
A lot. And Sean feel about him. Sean, I don't know if you've ever met him, but you may have. We're going to find out in a second. We're going to get on with it. Yeah. Will, it's our long lost brother, Tony Hale. Come on.
非常爱。肖恩对他感觉如何？肖恩，我不知道你以前有没有见过他，但你可能见过。我们马上就会知道。我们要开始了。对。威尔，他是我们失散多年的兄弟，托尼·海尔。来吧。
Tony. Hello. Hey. What's up? What are you talking about? I live for Tony Hale. Wait. Have you guys met?
托尼。你好。嘿。怎么了？你在说什么？我为托尼·海尔而活。等等。你们见过面吗？
Many times. Yeah. Really? With me? No. Not with you? No. No.
很多次。真的吗？跟我？没有。没跟你？没有。没有。
Okay. Good. Actually, no, we did meet with you because it was out of, it was a party years ago at your house and I went up to you, Sean. At my house? No. At Jason's house. Okay.
好吧。太好了。其实，不对，我们确实跟你见过面，因为那是好几年前在你家举行的一个派对上，我朝你走过去，肖恩。在我家？没有。在杰森家。好吧。
I'm a big fan and you said, I'm a big fan of yours. Come to find out later. You never watched the rest of development. So you were lying. No. Well, I'm not a lie. I'm still, I can still be a fan. He's seen the commercials, Tony.
我是你的超级粉丝，你说：“我是你的超级粉丝。”后来我才发现。你根本没看过《发展受阻》。所以你在撒谎。不。好吧，我不是在撒谎。我还是——我依然可以是你的粉丝。他看过广告，托尼。
Really? Okay. Two tone. Oh, baby. I've probably seen Veeb. I love Tony so much. That's another thing I could have put in the intro that I get. I can raw dog.
真的吗？好吧。双色调。哦，宝贝。我可能看过《副总统》。我太爱托尼了。这是我本来可以放进开场白里的另一件事，我可以直接开干。
He's been on Veeb. Well, if you had said Veeb, I just would have known immediately. Exactly. But wait, Tony, hang on. I just got to absorb this. Tony. I'm so happy to be here. Guys, that was really hard not to laugh.
他演过《副总统》。好吧，如果你早说《副总统》，我马上就能知道了。没错。等等，托尼，等一下。我得好好消化一下。托尼。我太高兴能来到这里了。伙计们，刚才真的很难忍住不笑。
Really, really hard not to laugh. Tony and I knew it. Are we talking about the same thing? That made me laugh out loud in my mouth, in my hand. I've forgotten when you were just, when you hadn't revealed yourself, I've forgotten what a heavy breather you are. And so I just...
真的，真的很难忍住不笑。托尼和我都心知肚明。我们是在说同一件事吗？那句话让我笑出了声，捂着嘴笑。我刚才都忘了，当你还没自报家门的时候，我差点忘了你是个多么喜欢重重喘气的人。所以我只是——
Well, asthma. Asthma, thanks for bringing it up. Oh, really? Yeah. I meant that in a good way, by the way. Oh, you didn't? Oh. Okay.
好吧，哮喘。哮喘，谢谢你提起它。哦，真的吗？对。我刚才那是好意，顺便说一句。哦，不是吗？哦。好吧。
So you had asthma for a long time? I have since I was a kid. Oh, that's right. I knew this. I knew this. Of course, I did not. What do you mean you knew this? We talked about it on your podcast.
所以你得哮喘很久了吗？我从小就有。哦，对哦。我知道这个。我知道这个。当然，我其实并不知道。什么叫你知道这个？我们在你的播客里聊过。
Yeah. Oh, wait. Was Tony on Hypocondry Actor? Yeah. Oh, no way. This is a crossover episode. He played Gary Walsh on Veeb. Uh-oh.
对。哦，等等。托尼上过《疑病症演员》播客吗？对。哦，不会吧。这是跨界联动集。他在《副总统》里饰演加里·沃尔什。噢。
We already did the intro, Jay. We already did the intro. He won an Emmy in 2013 and 2015 for Veeb, because I know he didn't win for Arrested. I was sitting next to Tony when he won... Yeah, you were. But then Jason was in front. In front.
我们已经做过开场白了，杰伊。我们已经做过开场白了。他在2013年和2015年凭《副总统》赢得过艾美奖，因为我知道他没凭《发展受阻》得过奖。托尼获奖时我就坐在他旁边……对，你是坐在旁边。但当时杰森坐在前面。前面。
And Jason was in front when they called member Jay when he got his first Emmy. How about that? He's not going to remember. I don't remember anything. I know... Okay, listen, Tony... Guess what, guys?
当他们宣读杰伊的名字、他第一次获得艾美奖时，杰森就坐在前面。那次怎么样？他才不记得呢。我什么都不记得了。我只知道——好吧，听着，托尼……你们猜怎么着，伙计们？
His birthday is September 30th and he's 51. Good. Good. Good. Good. I don't need the Wikipedia to tell me his wife's name is Martell. I love her and I miss her. And Loy is still your daughter?
他的生日是9月30日，今年51岁。很好。很好。很好。很好。我不需要维基百科告诉我他太太的名字叫玛黛尔。我爱她，我也很想念她。露伊还是你的女儿吗？
She's not. Oh. I know. Oh, she retired. That's too bad. We had a hard break up. Didn't work out. Oh, Tony.
已经不是了。哦。我知道。哦，她退休了。太遗憾了。我们经历了一次艰难的分手。没能走到一起。哦，托尼。
She's now... She's 16 now. Wow. She's a junior in high school. She's driving. And... Because Franny's about to start driving. She's driving.
她现在——她现在16岁了。哇。她上高中十一年级了。她会开车了。而且——因为弗兰妮也快要开始学开车了。她会开车了。
Yeah. She's driving. How did that go for you and Martell? It's been a journey. It's the highways that do freak me out. Sure. A little bit, the LA Highways. So I was driving home just now.
对。她会开车了。你和玛黛尔感觉怎么样？这一路走来挺不容易的。那些高速公路确实让我抓狂。当然。稍微有点，洛杉矶的高速公路。所以我刚才开车回家的时候。
I picked up Archie from school with his pal. And I was driving back and I was coming up cold water. And I see these two teenagers trying to make a left-hand turn in Russian traffic. And so I stopped to let them go because they were trying to take a left in front of me and to go the direction I was going. And everybody else coming down cold water was not having it. And these kids, they pulled out and they went back. And I just stopped and I held and I kept flashing my light.
我接阿奇放学，还有他的小伙伴。我开着车往回走，正驶向科尔德沃特峡谷大道。我看到两个青少年在湍急的车流中试图左转。所以我停下来让他们先过，因为他们想在我前面左转，开往我正要去的方向。而其他从科尔德沃特峡谷大道开下来的人根本不给他们机会。这两个孩子把车开了出去，然后又倒了回去。我停下车，保持住，一直向他们闪烁车灯。
And I put my hand out the window like, guys, go. And I could see that they were barely 16. And it made me so nervous for them. And then they finally, one other person... They were confused by your kindness, right? Well, yeah, but the people in the other way, and I just thought as they went out, I just, I wanted, of course, as you know at Single Lane, I wanted to pull up to them and teach them a lesson and literally go like,
我把手伸出窗外，示意他们：伙计们，走吧。我能看出他们才刚满16岁。这让我为他们捏了一把汗。然后他们终于，另有一个人——他们被你的善良搞糊涂了吧？嗯，对，但是反方向的人——我当时就想，当他们开出去的时候，当然，正如你在单行道上所知道的那样，我想把车开过去教训他们一顿，字面意思上地对他们说：
guys, you need to know something. Just be careful, please. I was so nervous for them as a dad. We're such old men now. I know. Right? Just a few years ago. Yeah. You would have just been honking and saying, get the hell out of the car.
伙计们，你们得知道一件事。请务必小心。作为父亲，我当时为他们捏了一把汗。我们现在真是老头子了。我知道。对吧？就在几年前。对。你肯定会按喇叭，然后说：“滚出车里去！”
I know. So Tony Hale, so to Tracy, Tony... So fun. This is so fun. This is amazing. Tony and I met first. I just want to say, I know Jason is your guest, but I'm going to hog this. I want to say...
我知道。所以，托尼·海尔，还有特雷西，托尼——太有趣了。这太有趣了。太棒了。托尼和我最早认识。我只想说，我知道杰森是你的嘉宾，但我打算独占风头。我想说——
Go, please. I'm unprepared. No, good. Martell, Martell, his wife used to work on SNL. And so our wife... Started the Night Live, Tracy. Started the Night Live, Tracy, which is a longstanding live sketch comedy. Okay. Okay.
请说，请说。我毫无准备。不，很好。玛黛尔，玛黛尔，他的妻子以前在《周六夜现场》工作。所以我们的妻子——《周六夜现场》，特雷西。《周六夜现场》，特雷西，这是一个历史悠久的现场素描喜剧节目。好吧。好吧。
And... When do they shoot that? Oh, my God. They, so they knew each other before. So then Tony and I went out to read for Rest of the Development, which is a longer story. And we kind of had a little bit of a... We kind of knew each other a little bit. Like, hey, hey, we had that familiarity.
而且……他们是什么时候拍那个的？天哪。他们，所以他们之前就认识。然后托尼和我一起去试镜《发展受阻》，那是个挺长的事。我们当时有点——我们俩其实有点面熟。就像，嘿，嘿，我们有一种熟悉感。
From the halls of SNL? Because our wives knew each other. And it was nerve... We were both... It was very nerve-racking. We were both staying at what was then the Intercontinental Hotel in Century City. And we walked to our test together. Yeah.
从《周六夜现场》的后台？因为我们的妻子互相认识。而且很紧张——我们俩当时——非常紧张。我们当时都住在世纪城的洲际酒店（当时叫这个名字）。我们一起步行去试镜。对。
You remember that? For Rest of the Development? For Rest of the Development, Tony and I walked... You both got it. We both got it. And we both got it. Wait, so you walked down... Sean's just now learning that we both got it.
你还记得吗？为了《发展受阻》？为了《发展受阻》，托尼和我一起走过去——你们俩都通过了。我们俩都通过了。而且我们俩都通过了。等等，所以你们走过去——肖恩现在才知道我们俩都通过了。
We walked to the back gate. We went in... What's that called? The Galaxy Gate. Yeah, yeah. And we went in the back together. And then we walked over and read with you and with Portia and Jessica and everybody. Yeah.
我们走到后门。我们进去了——那叫什么来着？银河门。对，对。我们一起从后门进去的。然后我们走过去，和你们、波西亚、杰西卡以及所有人一起围读剧本。对。
And then we both got it. And then we walked... And then we were like, I guess we're staying for a little bit. Yeah. Did you... Correct me if I'm wrong. Did we shoot the pilot right after we had that callback? Well, yeah.
然后我们俩都通过了。然后我们走——然后我们当时想，看来我们要在这呆上一阵子了。对。你们——纠正我如果我记错了。我们在那次试读之后马上就拍了试播集吗？嗯，对。
Tony, remember the next night? I'm good with stuff like this, Jason will tell you. Okay. The next night we had a read through... What year was this, Will? This is the spring... 2003. This is late February of 2003, Tony knows.
托尼，还记得第二天吗？我对这种事很在行，杰森会告诉你的。好吧。第二天我们进行了一次剧本围读——这是哪一年，威尔？这是2003年的春天……这是2003年2月下旬，托尼知道的。
Wait, how do you know the month free? Because... By the way, by the way, in this spring, it's going to be 20 years since we shot the pilot, 20 years ago. Really? And when does it come out? It's going to... Turn your camera off right now, Sean.
等等，你怎么知道具体哪个月的？因为……顺便说一句，顺便说一句，今年春天距离我们拍摄试播集已经过去20年了，整整20年了。真的吗？那是什么时候播出的？它将要——把你的摄像头关掉，肖恩。
Anyway, so that's... Tony and I... It's been shelved for 20 years. And then, and I will say this, and I've told this and I've said it high and wide. Frame it up better. There is nobody on the set, and Jason, you're there, and I'm sorry to say, but there's nobody who cracked me up. And I think you'll attest to this too, the way Tony hailed it.
不管怎样，所以这就是——托尼和我……它被雪藏了20年。然后，我要说的是，我到处跟人说过这事。把它表述得更好一点。片场没有任何一个人——杰森，你也在场，我很抱歉这么说——但没有人能像托尼·海尔那样把我逗得前仰后合。我想你也会对此作证的。
David Kropp. Oh, Tony, yeah. No, I... I listened to David's podcast you guys did with him. And Will, when you said the best joke that he said, and when he said, I don't know what you said, Jason, like, how are you doing? He goes, good. And he goes, it's going to be good.
大卫·克罗斯。哦，托尼，对。不，我——我听了你们俩采访大卫的播客。威尔，当你说到他说过最好笑的笑话时，你说——我不知道你当时说了什么，杰森，比如“你最近怎么样？”他说：“挺好的。”然后他说：“这会是一部好剧的。”
Yeah. That was... Remember that? That's the best line ever. That was so funny. But Tony... Tony would do this thing where he'd be getting ready to... Like he and I would both be off-camera, ready to enter a scene.
对。那是——还记得吗？那是史上最棒的台词。太搞笑了。但托尼——托尼会做这样一件事，他当时在准备——比如他和我都还没入镜，准备进入一个场景。
And Jason, you know that thing where he... He starts getting into buster, yeah. And he'd start getting into buster. So he'd be talking to him about something. He'd go, someone like, I think we're wrapping later. And he'd go, yeah, and then you'd hear the scene go, okay, I got it. And then he'd go like... And you'd bring up the Tyrannosaurus Rex hands.
杰森，你知道那种情况吗？他——他开始进入巴斯特的状态了，对。然后他就会进入巴斯特的状态。所以他会跟别人聊点什么。他会说，比如我觉得我们稍后收工。然后他会说，对，然后你就会听到场景里说：“好吧，我懂了。”接着他就会像这样——然后你就摆出了霸王龙的手势。
And you'd bring his hands up like this, and I would... And then I'd have to come in after him, and I'd be in Tyrannosaurus Rex hands. Tony, fuck me, Tony, you're so goddamn funny. He tucks the chin and brings up the Tyrannosaurus Rex hands, and then he's in. I took it really seriously. Well, now, well, tell me about that. Is that... Because I haven't worked with you before or since, unfortunately.
然后你把双手像这样抬起来，我就会——然后我得在他后面出场，我也得摆出霸王龙的手势。托尼，操，托尼，你太特么搞笑了。他收起下巴，摆出霸王龙的手势，然后就进入角色了。我当时真的很认真。好吧，现在，跟我说说这个。那是——因为我之前和之后都没跟你合作过，遗憾的是。
But was your... Are you that disciplined with everything you do or did you think at the time, this is a big deal, a big show? Yeah. I better keep it tight because this feels large. Yeah. I was... I think I was so... I think all that. I was really overwhelmed. I was really intimidated.
但你的——你对你做的所有事情都这么自律吗？还是你当时觉得，这是一件大事，一部大制作？对。我最好把它演好，因为这感觉责任重大。对。我当时——我想我当时太——我想所有这些。我当时真的很不知所措。我真的很紧张。
And I was like, I gotta do the work. And so I would go back to my hotel room and I would just like practice in the mirror and all that stuff. Because I will say, I went up to Mitch and I asked a very active question. Mitch Orwitz was the boss on the show, Tracy. Mitch Orwitz, yeah. He was a guest. I'm here, too.
然后我想：“我得把工作做好。”所以我回到了酒店房间，我就会在镜子里练习所有这些东西。因为我要说的是，我走到米奇面前问了一个非常主动的问题。米奇·奥维茨是剧组的老板，特雷西。米奇·奥维茨，对。他曾是嘉宾。我也在这呢。
Sweet Tracy. And I asked him, I said, what does Buster want in life? And he said, I know, it's a really active question. And he goes, all he wants in life is safety. And so then I just kind of like thought everything that threatened his safety, he would just like panic. And so he was always in a state of defense, like his chin would go back, his hands would go back.
可爱的特雷西。我问他，我说：“巴斯特在生活中想要什么？”我知道，这是一个非常主动的问题。他说：“他一生想要的只有安全感。”所以然后我就想，任何威胁到他安全的事都会让他恐慌。所以他总是处于防守状态，比如他的下巴会缩回去，双手会缩回去。
And he was just, just constantly waiting for what's going to come out of him. That's really funny. Sean, you have to know you'd be doing a seat and then you'd be like, and even when you were rolling and if Tony was behind you and you'd be having a conversation, like you'd say Jason, I'd be like, blah, blah, blah. And then you'd just hear, oh. You could always hear what's going on inside. He'd sort of verbalize it.
他一直在——一直在等待会有什么状况发生在他身上。这真的太搞笑了。肖恩，你肯定知道，当你正在拍一场戏的时候，哪怕是在开拍中，如果托尼在你身后，而你们正在对话，比如你会对杰森说，我会说：“巴拉巴拉巴拉。”然后你就会听到：“哦。”你总能听到他内心在发生什么。他会把那种情绪下意识地表达出来。
And I have a really fat chin, which actually helped because it would just like, no, you do not. I have a question about, I heard about, like, I don't know the process on arrest development. It sounds like it was, obviously I've heard so many stories. Oh, it was a good time, Sean. Yeah. Good shows. Good episodes.
而且我有一个非常肉乎乎的下巴，其实这很有帮助，因为它会显得——不，你才没有。我有一个关于——我听说过，我不了解《发展受阻》的制作流程。听起来——显然我听过很多故事。哦，那是一段美好的时光，肖恩。对。好剧。好剧集。
And I'm sure you, I like it as much as you like. Save it though. Will and Grace, you know. I'm curious, have you seen, I mean, have you literally seen anything? I saw the first two. I laughed out loud. Oh, you did see the first two. Yeah.
我确信你，你和我都一样喜欢。不过先别提这个了。《威尔和格蕾丝》，你知道的。我很好奇，你看过吗？我是说，你真的看过任何内容吗？我看过前两集。我笑出声了。哦，你确实看过前两集。对。
That was enough. Not for him. You're that person. You're that person. You're that person. There's a problem and it gets resolved. Okay. So, but, um, on Veep, I heard, um, that there's a, there's an actual, I don't know if this
这就够了。对他来说不够。你就是那种人。你就是那种人。你就是那种人。出了问题，然后问题得到解决。好吧。所以，但是，在《副总统》剧组，我听说，有一个实际上的——我不知道这是不是
is true. This, I've always wanted to ask you this, that there is a process, actual rehearsal process, like a lengthy one. Can you describe that to me? Because I'm kind of really interested in that where you got to improvise scenes, even though they were written, or did you improvise them first and the writers would write from what you came up with? Uh, I think a little bit of both.
真的。我一直想问你这个，那里有一个流程，一个实际的排练流程，而且非常漫长。你能给我描述一下吗？因为我对这个真的很有兴趣，你们必须即兴发挥场景，尽管剧本是写好的，还是说你们先即兴发挥，然后编剧根据你们想出来的东西来写剧本？呃，我觉得两者都有点吧。
Armando Iannucci, who created it, he would give us, he would give us, Armando Iannucci. No. Armando Iannucci. Isn't it Armando Iannucci? How many years did you guys work together? Yeah. This is probably seven or eight. I think it's Armando.
阿曼达·伊纳努奇（Armando Iannucci），他是创作者，他会给我们——阿曼达·伊纳努奇。不对。阿曼达·伊纳努奇。难道不是阿曼达·伊纳努奇吗？你们俩一起工作了多少年？对。这大概有七八年吧。我觉得是阿曼达。
This is Veep. I think it's Armando Iannucci. You think? So he was a passive producer? We would call him Arm. We would call him Arm. Arm. I don't care about his full name.
这是《副总统》。我觉得是阿曼达·伊纳努奇。你觉得？所以他是个消极的制作人？我们叫他阿姆。我们叫他阿姆。阿姆。我才不在乎他的全名是什么。
Yeah. But I think it's like, I'm pretty sure it's Armando. By the way, by the way, we just found our promo clip. Armando Iannucci. But he would kind of give us a scenario. And the, because Matt Walsh was also in Veep, you know, who's like a master improver and he helped create UCB and all this stuff. And so all of us had to kind of get on the routine.
对。但我觉得就像——我很确信是阿曼达。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，我们刚刚找到了宣传剪辑片段。阿曼达·伊纳努奇。但他会给我们设定一个情景。因为马特·沃尔什也在《副总统》里，你知道的，他是一个即兴表演大师，他帮助创立了UCB（直立公民剧团）以及所有这些。所以我们所有人都得融入这种日常。
Like it's not necessarily about coming up with funny bits. It was just kind of, he just wanted to see if it gelled and then out of that funny bits would come. No, we never rehearsed on Arrested. We rarely had any rehearsal on TV. No, right. Yeah. That's why I was asking just because on Veep, so you would rehearse what?
这不一定是为了想出什么搞笑的段子。这更像是，他只是想看看我们能不能合拍，然后从那种默契中自然而然地诞生出搞笑的段子。不，我们在《发展受阻》里从来不排练。我们在电视上很少有排练。不，对吧。对啊。我刚才之所以问，是因为在《副总统》里，你们会排练什么？
A week before you even started shooting? Yeah. We would shoot, we would fly down because we shot in Baltimore. So we'd fly down a couple of weeks before we'd shoot and just like go to this room. For every episode? A week for every episode? No, no, no, no. No.
在你们开机拍摄前的一周？对。我们会飞过去，因为我们在巴尔的摩拍摄。所以我们会在拍摄前几周飞过去，然后去这个房间。每一集都这样？每一集都排练一周？不，不，不，不。
It was like, we would do like five scripts or something like that. I just kind of feel those out. Wow. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Sorry. What happens? So there's a script that's written? Yeah.
大概是，我们会把五集剧本左右放在一起。我只是凭感觉说说。哇。等等，等等，等等，等等。抱歉。怎么回事？所以剧本是写好的？对。
There's a script that's written? Ish. So yeah, the script is, they have a really good idea of the script and then a lot is written, but then they kind of throw out, they say, ask to kind of throw away the script and just kind of play with the scene. So it's like, we would do some of the lines and not do some of the lines, but it was more of just like, if the story is working, if the relationships are working, if bits do come out, but like...
剧本是写好的？差不多吧。所以，是的，剧本——他们对剧本有一个非常好的构思，然后很多内容是写出来的，但接着他们会抛弃——他们说，让大家把剧本先抛在一边，就顺着场景自由发挥。所以，我们会演一些台词，也会不演一些台词，但这更多的是关于——故事是否顺畅，人物关系是否奏效，如果能碰撞出段子固然好，但就像——
You guys sound like storytellers. Yeah. So wait, so then they would then see what you guys would improvise in addition to what is written. And then if the improvised dialogue is worthy of being included in this half-written script, it would. Yes? Yeah.
你们听起来像是在讲故事。对。所以，等一下，然后他们会看你们在写好的剧本之外即兴发挥了什么。如果即兴发挥的对话值得被收录进这个半成品的剧本里，就会被采纳。对吗？对。
Well, thanks for making it sound less fun, but yeah. And then a week later, you then have a complete script and that's the script that you would then shoot? Yeah, but even in that complete script, if stuff came out, it was a very open environment. Yeah. You should see Jason explain to kids on how to get on a bouncy house. He really... So you go in, the air is pumped up and it keeps...
好吧，谢谢你把它说得没那么有趣，不过是的。然后在一周后，你们就会有一个完整的剧本，这就是你们要拍的剧本？对，但即便在那份完整的剧本里，如果有新的点子冒出来，那也是一个非常开放的环境。对。你应该看看杰森是怎么向孩子们解释怎么玩充气城堡的。他真的——所以你进去，气是充足的，它保持着——
I want you to unlace your shoes. And then your socks because of... Lay them outside. Your ligaments and the buoyancy. Now, Tony, I saw, I remember seeing a long time ago, didn't you do Drunk History like even more than once? Yeah, several times. Yeah, I love that show.
我希望你们解开鞋带。然后是袜子，因为——把它们放在外面。你们的韧带和浮力。现在，托尼，我看到——我记得很久以前，你是不是演过《醉酒史》？甚至不止一次？对，好几次。对，我超喜欢那个节目。
It was so fucking funny. And I learned a lot too. By the way, dumb, dumb question, because I know nothing about that show other than it's hilarious and you were great. They really make you drink until you can't do it. I wasn't the storyteller. I know, I know, but I mean like the people that are... Yeah.
太特么搞笑了。而且我也学到了很多。顺便说一句，问个很蠢的问题，因为我对那个节目一无所知，只知道它爆笑，而且你演得很好。他们真的会让你喝到烂醉，直到你演不动为止吗？我当时不是讲故事的人。我知道，我知道，但我的意思是，那些——对。
Yeah, I think they get them really drunk and then they have them kind of retell... Just like they're totally... Tell the story. And the thing is, there's stuff that I learned from that show that I never knew. Just the way they said it. It was just... About puking? Oh, puking.
对，我想他们会让那些人喝得烂醉，然后让他们重新讲述——就好像他们完全——讲那个故事。关键是，有些东西我是从那个节目里学到的，是我以前从未知道的。就他们说话的那种方式。简直是——关于呕吐？哦，呕吐。
I learned a lot about how you throw up your meals. Tony was a Sigma Chi for Tony. Okay. He's back in Wikipedia. You went to Samford University, which was started by Red Fox and his son. I was... I actually... I'm in Nashville right now because I'm doing a movie here with my friend Seth Worley and
我学到了很多关于你是怎么把吃的东西吐出来的知识。托尼以前是西格玛·基兄弟会的成员。好吧。他又开始查维基百科了。你去了桑福德大学，那是红福克斯和他的儿子创办的。我当时——其实——我现在在纳什维尔，因为我在这里和我的朋友塞思·沃利（Seth Worley）拍一部电影，
it's like two hours from Alabama, so I went and visited some friends from college and then Martell's family. So I was just there. Come on. Samford. Oh, that's nice. Did you go back to the Sigma Chi fraternity house? I did not.
这里离阿拉巴马州大概有两个小时车程，所以我去拜访了一些大学的朋友，还有玛黛尔的家人。所以我刚好在那儿。拜托。桑福德。哦，那挺好的。你回西格玛·基兄弟会的那栋房子看过了吗？我没有。
Where you got your journalism degree in 1992? I did not. Okay. Well, he didn't get his degree from... He doesn't know how college works, but hey, Tony, so you've always had... Well, I'm here to learn. Both you and Martell are from the South as you just sort of alluded to. Yeah.
你在那里获得了1992年的新闻学学位？我没有。好吧。好吧，他可没从那拿到学位——他根本不懂大学是怎么运作的。不过，嘿，托尼，所以你一直都有——好吧，我是来学习的。正如你刚刚提到的那样，你和玛黛尔都来自南方。对。
And you maintain the Southern Rouge. This is so fun. This is so fun. You have a lot of credits on here. It's just so... Because... I don't know what... They've done a couple of episodes of Samantha Who.
而且你一直保持着南方的口音。这太有趣了。这太有趣了。你这里有好多演艺履历。这简直——因为——我不知道什么——他们客串过好几集的《萨曼莎是谁？》。
Okay. We got to get past this. God, this is fantastic. We'll be right back. Hey, smart list listeners. We are supported by Verizon. You want a wireless plan that doesn't come with a catch? And you want visible.
好吧。我们得跳过这个了。天哪，这也太精彩了。我们马上回来。嘿，“聪明人”听众们。我们得到了威瑞森（Verizon）的支持。你想要一个没有隐形消费的无线套餐吗？那你想要Visible。
They're a wireless company that doesn't do catches, which means you don't need a family plan to save. Visible starts at just 30 bucks a month for a one line wireless plan, taxes and fees included. No family plan needed. You get unlimited data and hotspot, which means you can stream as much as you want from pretty much anywhere seriously. It's all powered by Verizon. Yep.
他们是一家没有隐形消费的无线公司，这意味着你不需要为了省钱而加入家庭套餐。Visible单线无线套餐起价仅为30美元/月，已包含税费。无需家庭套餐。你可以获得无限流量和热点，这意味着你可以真正地随时随地尽情播放流媒体。这一切都由威瑞森提供技术支持。没错。
That network. And now they have a new plan that includes 5G ultra wide band and global calling. So you score a premium network experience. Switch today at visible.com, 5G ultra wide band and global calling available only on the visible plus plan for data management practices. Learn more at visible.com. Additional terms apply. Smart list is brought to you in part by nationwide.
就是那个网络。现在他们推出了包含5G超宽带和全球通话功能的新套餐，让你享受优质的网络体验。今天就登录visible.com切换套餐吧。5G超宽带和全球通话仅适用于Visible Plus套餐。关于数据管理做法，请访问visible.com了解更多信息。其他条款适用。“聪明人”播客的部分内容由Nationwide保险公司为您呈现。
Halloween is one of my favorite holidays ever of the year. I love it. It's cozy. It's fun to go out and celebrate. But at home, you know, we have Ricky, our dog, and I like to dress him up as a falc or from a never ending story. Anybody? Yeah, because he looks just like it even without a costume.
万圣节是我一年中最喜欢的节日之一。我太喜欢了。它很温馨，出门庆祝也很有趣。但在家里，你知道的，我们有我们的狗狗里基（Ricky），我喜欢把它打扮成《大荒野历险记》里的法考（Falkor）或者《永不结束的故事》里的角色。有人知道吗？对，因为即使不穿戏服，它长得也跟那个一模一样。
But people go, oh my God, is that the thing from the movie? I'm like, yeah, that's actually him. Trick or treating can be super fun for both people and pets, but it can also get scary. And not just because of things that go boop in the night. Our friends at nationwide put together some Halloween safety tips for you and your pets. Pushing up your pet, make sure you choose a comfortable costume that won't pinch or choke and that's free of loose wings, strings or bows. Keep the candy bowl out of reach.
但人们总是会说：“天哪，那是电影里的那个东西吗？”我说：“对，其实那就是它本尊。”万圣节讨糖果对人和宠物来说都超级有趣，但也可能会变得很吓人。不仅仅是因为那些黑夜里发出撞击声的东西。我们在Nationwide的朋友为您和您的宠物整理了一些万圣节安全小贴士。给宠物打扮时，请确保选择舒适的戏服，不会夹到或勒到它们，并且没有松动的翅膀、带子或蝴蝶结。把糖果碗放在它们够不到的地方。
Please ingestion of chocolate or sugar free candies can lead to a trip to the emergency room for your pet. Halloween is a common holiday for pets to get lost. Please make sure your pet is wearing up to date tags and is micro chipped nationwide protects pets from unexpected frights on Halloween night and all year round. Don't reimburse for eligible expenses related to injuries, illnesses and more. Go to petinsurance.com slash smartless to get a quote today. Nationwide is on your side.
请注意，误食巧克力或无糖糖果可能会导致您的宠物不得不去急诊室。万圣节是宠物走失的高发节日。请确保您的宠物佩戴了最新的身份标牌并植入了微芯片。Nationwide在万圣节之夜以及全年保护宠物免受意外惊吓。不报销与伤害、疾病等相关的符合条件的费用。访问petinsurance.com/smartless获取今日报价。Nationwide与您同在。
Thanks to native for their support. Your shower routine. It's just that, right? A routine. You hop in, quickly lather up, rinse and then hurry on with your day. If your shower routine needs a little refresh, then you have to try native. You have your back with body washes that will make that time in the shower less routine and level up that shower game.
感谢Native对本节目的支持。你的淋浴流程。不也就是那样吗？成了一种例行公事。你跳进浴室，快速打上泡沫，冲洗干净，然后匆忙开始新的一天。如果你的淋浴流程需要一点新鲜感，那你一定要试试Native。他们的身体乳和沐浴露能让你的淋浴时间不再那么单调，让你的洗澡体验直接升级。
Natives clean effective body wash only uses simple ingredients that help cleanse your skin. Unlike other body washes that use sulfates to create a rich lather, native body wash offers that rich lather without the use of sulfates. Native body wash leaves your skin moisturized, silky smooth and residue free. When you shower with native, you will smell amazing long after your shower. Thanks to their long lasting sense, native has a scent option for everyone. Me, you know, I like s'mores, right?
Native清洁高效的沐浴露只使用简单的成分来净化你的皮肤。与其他使用硫酸盐产生丰富泡沫的沐浴露不同，Native沐浴露无需硫酸盐就能提供丰富的泡沫。Native沐浴露让你的皮肤水润、丝滑且无残留。当你使用Native沐浴露时，洗完澡后很久身上依然散发着迷人的香味。多亏了他们持久的留香，Native为每个人都提供了一种香味选择。就拿我来说吧，你知道的，我喜欢烤棉花糖，对吧？
I toast the little marshmallow on over the stove. I put the little, you know, like graham crackers in the chocolate. I love it. But what's more, they have a scent called toasted marshmallow and vanilla. Guess where I put it all over my body. So it doesn't just go inside my body when I eat a s'more. The smell is outside of my body and it is delicious. Try keeping Scotty away from that.
我在炉子上烤一小块棉花糖。我把全麦饼干和巧克力放进去。我太喜欢了。不仅如此，他们还有一款名为“烤棉花糖与香草”的香味。你猜我把它涂在哪儿了——我把它涂满了全身。所以它不仅在我吃棉花糖时进入我的体内。这种香味也在我的体外，而且闻起来太美味了。试着不让斯科蒂靠近那个味道吧。
Upgrade your shower routine with native body wash. Right now go to nativedo.com slash smartless or use promo code smartless at checkout to get 40% off your first three pack of native body wash. That's nativedeo.com slash smartless or use promo code smartless at checkout to get 40% off your first three pack of native body wash. That's nativedeo.com slash smartless or use promo code smartless. All right. Back to the show.
用Native沐浴露升级你的淋浴体验。现在访问nativedeo.com/smartless或在结账时使用优惠码smartless，即可在购买Native沐浴露前三件套时享受40%的折扣。网址是nativedeo.com/smartless，或在结账时使用优惠码smartless即可获得40%的折扣。网址是nativedeo.com/smartless，或使用优惠码smartless。好了。我们回到节目中。
Tony. So talk to us a little bit. So you're from the south. You grew up in the south and then you go, you moved to New York. We meet in New York. How did that happen? What was the move from college to New York and what was your goal? Okay.
托尼。给我们讲讲吧。所以你来自南方。你在南方长大，然后你搬到了纽约。我们在纽约相遇。那是怎么发生的？从大学搬到纽约的过程是怎样的？你的目标是什么？好吧。
So I moved to New York in 95, didn't know anybody. And then the very first theater show I did in New York was Shakespeare in the Parking Lot where we did Tammy in the Shoe in a Parking Lot. Are you being serious? I'm dead serious. That's hysterical. And then we did that. And then I had every job.
所以我是在1995年搬到纽约的，谁也不认识。然后我在纽约演的第一部戏剧是《停车场里的莎士比亚》，我们在停车场里演了《停车场里的塔米》。你是认真的吗？我绝对是认真的。太爆笑了。然后我们演了那个。接着我做过各种各样的工作。
I cater-weighted all that stuff. Actually really liked cater-weighting better than waiting tables. And so I cater-weighted all these jobs. And then I started doing commercials. And my type was the guy who wasn't all there. Oh, bless him. That's what I always described. And now become the Tony Hale type.
我做过餐饮服务外包的所有那些工作。其实我真的比在餐馆端盘子更喜欢餐饮外包。所以我做了所有这些餐饮服务的工作。然后我开始拍广告。我的戏路就是那种“脑子不太灵光”的家伙。哦，天哪。这就是我一贯的定位。现在这就成了“托尼·海尔式”戏路。
It really hasn't much changed. And so then I started doing commercials and enjoying it, but it took me six years to find an agent who would send me out for a TV and film because they saw me just as a commercial actor. Well, Sean, you did commercials for a long time, didn't you? A lot, yeah. Was there a lot of sort of, like there was a thing there, like a little stigma being like a commercial actor and the difference between that and doing film and TV?
其实一直没怎么变。然后我开始拍广告并且乐在其中，但我花了六年时间才找到一个愿意把我推去试镜电视剧和电影的经纪人，因为他们只把我当成广告演员。好吧，肖恩，你以前拍过很久的广告，对吧？拍了很多，对。当时是不是有一种——类似于对广告演员的偏见，以及广告和影视表演之间的差距？
Yeah. It was just, they were kind of putting you in compartments and it was just tough to get somebody to send me out for TV, film and theater. And there was this casting director named Marsha de Bonis. Oh yeah. Oh, the great Marsha de Bonis. Yeah. And she actually, I don't know if you, she's the one who I'd found.
对。就是他们会把你归类在不同的格子里，很难让人把你推去试镜电视剧、电影和戏剧。当时有一个选角导演叫玛莎·德·博尼斯（Marsha de Bonis）。哦，对。哦，伟大的玛莎·德·博尼斯。对。其实她——我不知道你记不记得，就是她发现了——
Cast, arrested. Yeah. I'd found a manager like a year before or something. So I was kind of being sent out for stuff. And then since she cast a lot of commercials, she thought about me for this role and brought me in. That's right. Marsha did the, she did the handle, the New York casting for arrested development.
选角，发展受阻。对。我大约在一年前左右找了个经纪人。所以他们开始把我推去试镜一些角色。既然她选了很多广告演员，她就想到了我，并把我叫来试镜。没错。玛莎负责——她负责《发展受阻》在纽约的选角。
Yeah. And, yeah. Yeah. And the whole, and Mitch said when I was, because Buster massaged people a lot and he's, and I was in the audition, I was massaging my knees and Mitch said, since the camera stopped here, he didn't know what I was doing down there and it piqued an interest and they sent me out. So it looked like you were doing something else.
对。而且，对。而且，米奇说过，当我——因为巴斯特经常给别人按摩，而且我在试镜时，我正在按摩我的膝盖，米奇说，由于摄像机只拍到这里，他不知道我在下面干什么，这引起了他的好奇，于是他们就把我叫去试镜了。所以看起来你在做别的事。
Yeah. Maybe. I was just, I mean, I don't, I don't, do you guys, I don't know, do you guys have much memory of that, that shooting that pilot? Cause I know we shot it at that. It was down south, right? And at the. The Raleigh Studios in Manhattan Beach.
对。也许吧。我是说，我不知道——你们伙计们——我不知道，你们对拍摄那部试播集还有多少记忆？因为我知道我们是在那个——那是在南方拍的，对吧？在——曼哈顿海滩的罗利制片厂（Raleigh Studios）。
Yep. It wasn't, was it a Manhattan Beach? Yes. Yes. Cause I, the only memory I have is I ran out, I remember running out of underwear and I had to go to old Navy to get underwear. And. Well, how does one run out of underwear?
是的。那不是——是在曼哈顿海滩吗？是的。是的。因为我——我唯一的记忆是我内衣穿完了，我不得不去海军老兵（Old Navy）买内衣。而且——
Is it because you, do you have too many mistakes in the day? I had five. I shit my pants five times. Don't start with Jason. You have to take care of the business before you leave the house for a second. Who goes shit in the middle of the day? Showering. Do you shower before or after?
话说回来，人怎么会把内衣穿完呢？是因为你——你一天里出了太多状况吗？我有五条。我特么拉了五次裤子。别拿杰森开涮。你出门前得先把个人卫生问题解决好。谁会大白天拉裤子啊？洗澡。你是在洗澡前还是洗澡后？
Oh my God. Oh my God. You know, Tony, it does say here that your father taught nuclear and atomic physics and served in the military. Yeah. He did. And he went to West Point. He went to West Point.
我的天呐。我的天呐。托尼，这上面确实写着你父亲教过核物理和原子物理，还在军队服役过。是的。他确实服役过。而且他还是西点军校毕业的。他毕业于西点军校。
Good Lord. And then he taught nuclear physics after, after he was done. At West Point. No. Yeah. He taught there after. And then he was in the military for 20 years and we moved around, we lived in Germany and everything.
天哪。然后他退伍后又去教核物理。在西点军校。不是。对的。他后来在那里教书。然后他在军队待了20年，我们搬来搬去，在德国等地都住过。
Will, do you feel as bad as I do that you don't know this about Tony after all the years we've worked together? I feel, what if Will's like, not really. I really don't know. I mean, I will. What if Will said, yeah. And his mom taught such and such and both like that you knew everything about Tony and I don't know.
威尔，我们合作这么多年了，你居然不知道托尼的这些事，你现在跟我一样觉得有点遗憾吗？我在想，要是威尔说，其实并没有。我真的不知道。我是说，我会。要是威尔说，是的。他妈妈教过什么什么的，就像你对托尼的事了如指掌，而我却不知道。
I didn't know that. I got to say, I am a little embarrassed to say that I didn't know that terrible. I love that kind of stuff. Did you ever get into that with your dad? Like, did you ever talk like, did any of that interest you? Because it interests me. I don't have it. Being in the military.
我以前不知道。我得说，对于自己居然不知道这件事，我感到有点尴尬，这太糟糕了。我挺喜欢那种东西的。你跟你父亲聊过这方面的经历吗？比方说，你们聊过吗，这些事引起过你的兴趣吗？因为我对这很感兴趣。我没有。在军队里呆过。
No, that. That. Nuclear physics. Like you must have, but that's like a double whammy for a military guy and a nuclear physicist to say, to hear his son say, I want to be an actor. You know, when my grandfather was an opera singer, so my dad had a real appreciation for the arts. So he always, always supported where I wanted to go, which I have memory.
不，那个。那个。核物理。就像你一定，但对于一个军人和核物理学家来说，听到自己的儿子说“我想当演员”，这简直是双重打击。你知道的，我外祖父曾经是个歌剧演员，所以我爸爸对艺术有着很高的欣赏力。所以他总是、总是支持我想走的路，这我一直都记得。
Did you have memories of that of your grandfather being an opera singer? He passed away when my dad was six. Oh, okay. Nice call. Well, he hit too high. No, it's not like Tony's. These guys are real jerks, Tony. Sorry about this.
你对你外祖父是歌剧演员这件事还有印象吗？我爸爸六岁时他就去世了。哦，好吧。猜得真准。好吧，他音调太高了。不，这不像托尼的风格。这几个人真是太讨厌了，托尼。真不好意思。
But like he, he never, he always, they always supported me, which is not always the case. So I'm really thankful for that. Your mom was the one that really was against the, the acting stuff. Go ahead. No. What? She loved it too. She did.
但就像他，他从来没有，他们总是、总是支持我，这可不是常有的事。所以我真的很感激。你妈妈才是那个真正反对演戏的人。你接着说。没有。什么？她也很喜欢。她真的喜欢。
I'm looking for controversy. He wants a real gotcha episode here with Tony. Wait, let me, let me just go through a couple. You guys talked to him for a second. I find out what mom was doing during all this. So, wait, wait, wait. You know, it says here, let me tell you, let me tell you what else it says here. Six nominations for Veep alone there on the Emmys, SAG awards, three nominations, another
我这是在挑起矛盾呢。他今晚是想在托尼这儿挖出一个猛料。等等，让我，让我再翻几个。你们俩先跟他聊一会儿。我来看看妈妈在这期间都在干嘛。所以，等等，等等。你知道，这上面写着，让我告诉你，让我告诉你这上面还写了什么。光是《副总统》就获得了六次艾美奖提名，还有演员工会奖的三次提名，另外
six for Veep. Tony, how many Emmy wins for Veep? Two? Two. Yeah. Two. For him. For him.
还有六次是凭《副总统》获得的。托尼，你凭《副总统》赢过多少次艾美奖？两次？两次。对。两次。他得的。他得的。
I think, oh, for me too, but for the show, I think it was two, I'm not sure. Yeah. That's so great. Such a funny show. It was a really, really funny show. I watched some of those outtakes between you and Julia and I'm die laughing. They're so funny. There's one scene where she has to, she has to, she asked me to break up with her boyfriend
我想，哦，我也得过，但就这部剧而言，我想是两次，我不太确定。对。太棒了。真是一部搞笑的剧。这真是一部非常非常搞笑的剧。我看过一些你和茱莉亚之间的片场花絮，我简直笑得要死。太搞笑了。有一个场景是她不得不，她不得不，她让我去和她的男友分手
for her in the first, in like the first season and she's so close proximity to me and it's almost, I mean, I remember all these moments when I'm arrested, it's so impossible to not laugh. You were great about not laughing though. It's just shaking. I wasn't in Veep. Julia said to me once, you know, you're not watching the show, you're in the show, Tony. Because I was laughing so hard, I couldn't keep it together.
在第一季的时候，而且她离我离得超级近，几乎，我的意思是，每当我想起这些我被抓包的时刻，就觉得太难不笑场了。不过你憋笑可真有一套。直哆嗦。我没演过《副总统》。茱莉亚有一次对我说，你知道的，你不是在看剧，你就在剧里，托尼。因为我笑得太厉害了，根本控制不住自己。
Was she fantastic at not breaking? She would always dig her nails into her hands to stop laughing. I do that. I pinch my thigh skin, but I brought blood. Are you doing a couple of psychotic things to not laugh? Well, I used to not be able to look at Jeffrey Tambor straight in the eyes when he would do scenes with me and he'd yell at me for like, they'd be staring at like, you know, the side of his cheek or the tip of his nose.
她憋笑的功夫是不是神了？她总是把指甲掐进手心里来克制笑意。我也这么干。我掐自己大腿上的肉，都掐出血了。你是不是也做了一些精神病一样的举动来忍住不笑？好吧，我以前跟杰弗里·坦伯尔演对手戏时，根本不敢直视他的眼睛，他会冲我大吼，你知道的，我只能盯着他脸颊的侧面或者鼻尖。
He was so dry. My thing is though, I don't know about you guys, but there were times that we just trusted Mitch's, the grid he had in his head because there were so many levels to what was going on. I had many times no idea what was going on and I just had to trust his guidance. At the time, especially the last couple of years, just so complex. Very complex. There was a joke.
他演得太冷幽默了。我的看法是，我不知道你们怎么想，但有时候我们就是无条件地信任米奇，信任他脑子里的整体构架，因为剧情的发展有太多层面的东西了。我有很多时候根本不知道发生了什么，只能盲目地相信他的引导。当时，尤其是最后几年，剧情太复杂了。非常复杂。有个笑话。
There was a joke. Well, somebody asked me once, what was your one of your favorite bits? And aside from Tobias being in the blue man group, which always made me laugh hard. The one joke when Ian Lesser, the doctor, Besser, Ian Roberts, yes, Ian Roberts came out and he would and Jessica would say, is he is he okay? And he'd go, yes, he's okay. And then he says, but his hand has been, it's been severed and they would get all mad. I just thought that was so hilarious the way he delivered it.
有个笑话。好吧，有人曾问我，你最喜欢的情节是哪一个？除了托拜厄斯加入蓝人乐团那段，那总是让我大笑不止。还有一个笑话是当伊恩·莱瑟，那个医生，贝瑟，伊恩·罗伯茨，是的，伊恩·罗伯茨走出来时，杰西卡会问，他，他还好吗？而他会回答，是的，他没事。然后他说，但是他的手已经，已经断了，然后他们就会气急败坏。我只是觉得他当时说话的语气太滑稽了。
Well, then I was on a, I was on a podcast like at the San Francisco sketch fest years ago in front of an audience. And I was saying though, it was my favorite joke. Somebody raised their hand and said, no, no, no, that's not what he said. He says, no, he's all right, meaning he has an all right hand and not a left hand. So 15 years after the joke is when I finally get it. That's America. And you were in the scene.
后来，好几年前，我在旧金山素描音乐节的一个播客节目里，当着观众的面。我当时正说着这是我最喜欢的笑话。有人举手说，不，不，不，他说的不是那个意思。他说的是，不，他右手没事，意思是他的右手完好，而不是左手。所以在这个笑话诞生15年后我才终于听懂了。这就是美国。而你当时就在那个场景里。
And I was in the scene. I mean, just so many things I missed. I love how they would just so proudly lean into cheap jokes, you know, like the, the C word was the name of the yacht, right? S E A W A R D C word. And then she and then we'd call her the C word, right? We call mom or she thought we were calling her the C word. I remember, you know, you call it the great Matt Walsh who was, he was with you on VP
而我当时就在那个场景里。我是说，有太多细节我都错过了。我喜欢他们那种故意厚着脸皮玩低俗梗的风格，你知道的，就像，那个以“C”开头的词是一艘游艇的名字，对吧？S-E-A-W-A-R-D，“C”开头的词。然后她，然后我们会叫她那个“C”开头的词，对吧？我们叫妈妈或者她以为我们在叫她那个“C”开头的词。我记得，你知道吧，你们管了不起的马特·沃什叫，他和你一起演过《副总统》
who's a hilarious guy and one of the founding members of upright citizen brigade and Ian Roberts as well. And I just, those doctor moments were so dry and so funny and Ian is so good in those moments. Yes. I can't imagine anybody else doing it. And he would do the, you know, the whole like, yes, they're, well, we lost them and everybody starts crying.
他是个超级搞笑的家伙，也是“功勋公民剧团”的创始人之一，伊恩·罗伯茨也是。那些医生的戏份真是冷幽默到了极点，也搞笑到了极点，伊恩在那些桥段里表现得太棒了。是的。我无法想象别人来演会是什么样。他会做那种，你知道的，整套的动作，是的，他们，好吧，我们失去他们了，然后每个人都开始哭。
They just literally meant that they lost them and those, those moments stick with me too. Those like guys like that coming in who are just absolute assassins, hilarious, God damn it. And Mitch, and Mitch just would just go, he would think of stuff that I would never even consider. I mean, obviously they'd have sealed it off my hand, but one is that when Jessica was on house arrest and she couldn't smoke and she needed me to inhale the smoke out of her mouth and then blow it out on the balcony to run out on the balcony and then come back
他们字面意思其实就是他们把人弄丢了，那些，那些时刻也深深印在我的脑海里。像他们那样的人走进来，简直就是绝对的幽默刺客，太搞笑了，真该死。还有米奇，米奇总是能想出我做梦也想不到的点子。我的意思是，很显然他们会把我的手封死，但其中一个桥段是，当杰西卡被软禁在家不能抽烟时，她需要我把她嘴里的烟雾吸出来，然后跑到阳台上去把它吐掉，跑到阳台上，然后又回来
like a baby bird and just, you know, suck it out of her mouth, just the most disturbing image. But Sean, you know what? Just keep watching. Just the two episodes. Don't worry about it. Okay. Yeah.
就像一只雏鸟一样，你知道的，从她嘴里把烟吸过去，这简直是最让人反胃的画面了。不过肖恩，你知道吗？继续看下去就行了。就看那两集。别担心。好吧。对。
Sean, how did you get, when you couldn't stop laughing, did you just go for it or did you keep yourself? Either one in grace. Yeah. Program. Wait, were you on that? Yeah. Oh, I've got to see that.
肖恩，你是怎么做到的？当你忍不住笑场时，你是顺其自然还是努力克制？两样都有，格蕾丝。对。节目。等等，你演过那个吗？对。哦，我得去看看。
No, I would, I had, I'm the easiest, I can't, I'm not, I'm the opposite of a rock on stage. I laugh at anything. It's so good. Tony, you know, one of the, one of my memories of you, one of my vivid memories in it and still alive today is, is what a kind person you are and how kind you are to people in your life and people around you. And it's one of the, it's one of the great things about you that makes you such a lovable and amazing person and I remember being, when we were shooting the show, so many great moments
不，我不会，我有，我是最容易笑的，我做不到，我可不是舞台上的一块顽石。我什么都能笑出来。太棒了。托尼，你知道吗，我对你的记忆中，有一个我最生动的记忆，而且至今依然历历在目，那就是你是一个多么善良的人，你对生活中的人和周围的人是多么的善良。这是你的优点之一，它让你成为了一个如此可爱和了不起的人，我记得当时，当我们正在拍这部剧时，有那么多美妙的时刻
where you were so sweet and kind, but I remember when we had first had Liza on the show, Manelli, and Liza came in and out over the years and was very open about being, going through moments in her life and whatever and was just, and you and Martell took, you know, you knew that she was in her hotel by herself and I remember you guys describing, you guys went and picked her up for dinner one night. What? Yeah. And she was in the back seat with no seatbelt on.
你总是那么甜美和善良，但我记得当我们第一次让丽莎上节目时，莉萨·明妮莉，丽莎这些年来断断续续地来过，她对自己在生活中经历的某些时刻一直非常坦诚，不管是怎样的时刻，而且——你和马特尔带着，你知道她一个人呆在酒店里，我记得你们描述过，你们有一天晚上去接她吃晚饭。什么？对。而且她坐在后座上连安全带都没系。
She had like a kid, remember like we used to do back in the 70s, she kind of leaned forward. I remember you describing between the seats, so smoking in Martell and Tony's car as they're driving to dinner. Talking to them. She insisted that she wanted us in the back seat and rolled the windows on, just immediately started chain smoking and I was like, please, please don't stop, like you can smoke as much as you want. And she...
她就像个小孩一样，还记得我们以前70年代常做的那样，她整个人往前倾。我记得你描述过，他们开车去吃晚饭时，马特尔和托尼的车里，大家隔着座位在聊天。跟他们说话。她坚持要我们坐在后座，把车窗摇上去，然后立刻开始不停地抽烟，我当时就想，求求你，求求你别停，你想抽多少就抽多少。然后她……
Where'd you guys go? I went to the hamburger hamlet and she was, she got in the back seat and she was talking about her music and talking about this concert. She did it, Radio City Music Hall and I was like, by the way, I'm still absorbing that Liza Minogue, my girlfriend. The whole thing is just incredibly surreal. We both kissed her on the unrested. And we both kissed her and she's talking about this concert and she says, oh, I sang and
你们去哪儿了？我去了汉堡哈姆雷特餐厅，她上了后座，开始谈论她的音乐，谈论她办的那场演唱会。她在无线城音乐厅办的，我当时就想，顺便说一句，我到现在还在消化“丽莎·明妮莉，我的好朋友”这件事。整件事简直魔幻得难以置信。我们在戒备状态下吻了她。我们俩都吻了她，然后她正谈着那场演唱会，她说，哦，我唱了
I said, what'd you sing? And she said, I sang the song Liza with a Z and I was like, oh, and I didn't know that song stupidly and I said, and so she broke out in the song in the back seat of our car and she sang it and just started singing it and she had done it so many times that she could hear the orchestration in her head and she'd go, Liza with a Z, ba-da-ba-ba-ba-bam! Just smoking and I was like, well, we can die, it's time to die, guys. She's just in the back hammering darts and I was just like, I don't know what's happening, but I'm just going to keep driving.
我说，你唱了什么？她说，我唱了那首歌《带着Z的丽莎》，然后我就想，哦，我当时很蠢地居然不知道这首歌，我说，于是她就在我们汽车的后座上唱起了这首歌，她唱了起来，情不自禁地开始唱，而且这首歌她唱了无数遍，以至于她脑子里能听到管弦乐的伴奏，她会唱：“带有Z的丽莎，巴-达-巴-巴-巴-班！”嘴里还叼着烟，我当时就想，好吧，我们要死了，伙计们，是时候去见上帝了。她就坐在后座上疯狂地吞云吐雾，而我当时就想，我不知道发生了什么，但我只能继续开车。
I remember you coming back after that weekend being like, well, we had a crazy weekend. But then she told it, then she would like go and just talked about her mom and she loved her mom and talk about being, she grew up on the MGM lot. That was pretty much her childhood. I mean, but her stories never came from a place of ego. They always came from a place of like, listen to my life, like this was my life, you know? You guys had some other big guest stars on there too, right? Marty Short was on there.
我还记得那个周末之后你回来时说，好吧，我们度过了一个疯狂的周末。但随后她又会说起，然后她就会顺便聊聊她的妈妈，她深爱着她的母亲，并谈论着自己在米高梅片场长大的经历。那几乎就是她的童年。我的意思是，但她的故事从来都不是出于自我中心。它们总是来自这样一种心态：听听我的人生吧，这就是我的人生，你知道吗？你们当时还邀请过其他一些大牌嘉宾，对吧？马蒂·肖特也来过。
Marty Short, great. Just shoot me. Yeah. He had lost use of his legs from a tragic weightlifting accident, right? He was clean and jerking and he got it up high and then too much and both legs went out from underneath them, snapped in half. And so he hired a bodybuilder to carry him around the rest of his life. Yeah, I remember it.
马蒂·肖特，太棒了。就叫《抑制热情》。对。他因为一次悲惨的举重事故失去了双腿的知觉，对吧？他当时在做抓举，举得很高，然后用力过猛，两边双腿从底下直接折断了。所以他雇了一个健美运动员余生背着他到处走。对，我记得。
A bodybuilder. Yeah. And he would try to get the nuts. He would like shoot for the nuts. And the guy would shoot him down so that he could get enough. What was the name of the bodybuilder? That's a great name. We had Carl Weathers.
一个健美运动员。对。他会试图去抓对方的命根子。他会瞄准人家的命根子。然后那家伙会把他打发掉，这样他就能拿到足够的报酬。那个健美运动员叫什么名字？那是个好名字。我们还请过卡尔·韦瑟斯。
We had, we had Super Dave Osborn. We had our buddy, Ed Begley was so hilarious. Yeah. Yeah. Obviously Henry Winkler, who's just... Obviously Henry. Yeah. Scott Beyo, Bob LaBlanc.
我们还请过，请过超级戴夫·奥斯本。我们还有老朋友爱德·贝格利，太搞笑了。对。对。显然还有亨利·温克勒，他简直……显然还有亨利。对。斯科特·拜奥，鲍勃·拉布兰克。
Yeah. We really... Look at it. We got to watch them all again. And we'll do it with Sean. It'll be new to you, Sean. It was a real embarrassment of riches, wasn't it? It really was.
对。我们真的……看呐。我们得把它们全部重温一遍。而且我们要和肖恩一起看。对你来说一切都是崭新的，肖恩。这真是一场幸福的烦恼，对吧？确实如此。
It was. Hey, so... Well, go ahead, Sean. Yeah. I was going to say, when you're... You're always, like Will was saying, always so funny, always working, by the way. And when you're not working, what are you doing? Because I like to know what rounds the person out.
确实是。嘿，那么……好吧，你接着说，肖恩。对。我本想说，当你……正如威尔所说，你总是那么幽默，而且顺便说一句，一直在工作。当你不工作的时候，你在干什么呢？因为我想了解一个人的生活全貌。
I actually got into making rope bowls. Hang on. Can I get into that? Can I show you? I'll show you a picture of them. A rope bowl. So a friend of mine... A friend of mine.
我最近迷上了做绳子碗。等一下。我可以聊这个吗？能给你们看吗？我给你们看张照片。一个绳子碗。所以我的一个朋友……我的一个朋友。
A friend of mine. What leader are you currently smoking these things? Yeah. Are you selling it or just smoking it now? Just a personal user. I started doing them over the pandemic because this... My friend, Shawna, on the show, I do mysterious benefit anxiety on Disney Plus. Shout out.
我的一个朋友。你现在抽的是什么牌子的烟？对。你是拿去卖还是现在只供自己抽？纯粹个人使用。大流行期间我开始做这个，因为这个……我的朋友肖娜，在节目里，我在迪士尼+上出演《神秘代号：贝尼迪克特学会》。顺便宣传一下。
She gave me one of these as a wrap gift and I was like, oh, this is the coolest thing. So I started doing these over the pandemic. Oh, yeah. So look, these are... Do you see them? Yes. What? Now, rope, it looked like pottery.
她把其中一个送给我当作杀青礼物，我当时就想，哦，这太酷了。所以我大流行期间就开始做这个。哦，对。所以看，这些是……你们看到了吗？看到了。什么？现在，绳子，它看起来像陶器。
It looked like a bowl. No, they're made out of rope. Really? And I really... It's incredibly therapeutic. Are they malleable? Like, can you move them? Yeah.
它看起来像个碗。不，它们是用绳子做的。真的吗？我真的很……这极其具有治疗效果。它们是可塑形的吗？比如，你能改变它们的形状吗？对。
Yeah. And you paint them and it's just like the best... What is it? Like, what would you put in a rope? His weed. A lot of his weed. Not food. It's not a lot of weed.
对，你可以给它们上色，这简直是最好的……是什么？比如，你会把什么放在绳子碗里？他的大麻。他的很多大麻。不是食物。不是很多大麻。
A lot of my weed. But it's like a decorative bowl. And it's like crochet? No, it's like you do like a disc and then you kind of mold the rope as you're sewing it and it becomes a bowl and then you get a leather... So I got a leather press to do... Wow, you're all in. To do these things.
我的很多大麻。但这就像一个装饰碗。就像是钩针编织的吗？不，就像是你先做一个盘子，然后你在缝的时候把绳子塑形，它就变成了一个碗，接着你弄一张皮革……所以我买了一个皮革压机来做……哇，你太投入了。来做这些东西。
And then you put a tag on there and I like to give them as gifts. What do you sell maybe on Etsy? Do you have a little site? I don't have an Etsy shop. How about any farmer's markets that you go to? No, for $5. Slice off a piece of soap and sell that with it. Hunk of soap with your bowl, ma'am.
然后你在上面贴个标签，我喜欢把它们当礼物送人。你在Etsy上卖吗？你有个小网店吗？我没有Etsy店铺。那你去过什么农夫市场吗？没有，售价5美元。切下一块肥皂跟它一起卖。买碗送肥皂，夫人。
Tony Hale, I love you so much. By the way. Now, does Martell help with this or does she mock you? No, she mocks me. But she likes to do these kind of number, these painting things. Well, paint by numbers, yeah. And so we had a table and then I would do that and she would do that over the pandemic.
托尼·海尔，我太爱你了。顺便说一句。话说回来，马特尔会帮你吗，还是她会嘲笑你？不，她嘲笑我。不过她喜欢搞这种数字涂色、画画之类的事情。哦，数字油画，对。所以我们有一张桌子，然后我会做那个，大流行期间她就会做那个。
And then Loy is doing what? While she's watching her parents go off the end. Just shaking her head, yeah. I kind of get it. I kind of want to take up crochet or something like that. You know, or like I get like the mindset of like... It's really... I put on these headphones, I listen to music
然后洛伊在干嘛？当她看着父母走向崩溃边缘时。只是直摇头，吧。我有点理解。我有点想学学钩针编织之类的事情。你知道，或者说我有点那种心态……这真的……我戴上耳机，听听音乐，
and it's just super meditative. And it's also, I'm not a painter, but I get to paint the rope. So that's kind of fun. And it's just very like soothing. Yeah. Sean, you should do that. Or tie like a stone to your leg and then go to the marina. Yeah, and see how many times you can get back up to the surface.
这超级有冥想的效果。而且，虽然我不是画家，但我可以给绳子涂色。所以这挺有意思的。而且感觉非常舒缓。对。肖恩，你也该试试。或者在腿上绑块石头，然后去码头。对，看看你能浮回水面几次。
Okay. You guys, can somebody give me a lift? Hey, wait. So Tony, so you're doing that, but if you're not pressing the leather, what else are you doing? Are you reading these days? Are you doing like... Are you watching Telly?
好吧。各位，谁能捎我一段？嘿，等等。所以托尼，你一直在做那个，但如果不压皮革的话，你还在做什么？最近在看书吗？你在做像……你在看电视吗？
I watch a lot of YouTube. Arts and crafts station? No. Okay. This is... You were so controversial. Tony, you were so controversial. I'm not a big T.
我看了很多YouTube视频。艺术和手工艺频道？不。好吧。这是……你太有争议了。托尼，你太有争议了。我不是个狂热的T……
I have to... I do like TV, but sometimes it's too heavy. You know, it's like... Do you watch comedy? I do some, but Martell watches really like she loves Ozark. She loves like handmates. She likes heavy stuff. Really?
我必须……我确实喜欢看电视，但有时候内容太沉重了。你知道，就像……你看喜剧吗？我偶尔看一些，但马特尔看的剧真的——她超爱《黑钱胜地》。她超爱《使女的故事》。她喜欢沉重的东西。真的吗？
I have... It really, it affects me. It's like horror movies when people are like, oh, wasn't that great? I'm like, no, someone's after me now. You know, it's like I can't detach. What about heavy reality shows? Like these guys are tired of me talking about alone. Like these survivalist shows.
我有……这真的会影响我。就像恐怖电影一样，当人们说，哦，那不是很棒吗？我会想，不，现在有人在追杀我了。你知道，我就是无法抽离。那沉重的真人秀呢？就像这些家伙听腻了我谈论《独自生存》。就像这些求生类的节目。
I love it. I never got into it. It's too heavy, isn't it? That's a little... But here's the thing also is sometimes when these stories are so heavy and people are like, oh, well, Tony, it's just... And Martell's like, you're an actor. Like why can't you detach?
我超爱。我从来没入过坑。太沉重了，不是吗？那有点……但问题是，有时候当这些故事太沉重时，人们会说，哦，拜托，托尼，这只是……而马特尔会说，你是个演员。那你为什么就不能抽离呢？
Because in my mind I'm thinking, yeah, that might not be heavy, but someone's had that same experience somewhere. And I'm watching a visualization of that. And it's too much. You're paralyzing empathy. So I'll watch... Paralyzing sometimes. I'll feel everybody's feelings for them.
因为在我的脑海里我会想，是的，那可能不是真的沉重，但某人在某个地方确实经历过同样的经历。而我正在看它的具象化呈现。这太过了。你的共情能力已经瘫痪了。所以我只会看……有时候确实会瘫痪。我会替所有人去感受他们的情绪。
Yeah. But it's like I... There was on YouTube, sometimes I'll watch compilation videos of like X-Factor auditions or... I watch this. Really? The voice... And I only want to see when they win.
对。但就像我……在YouTube上，有时候我会看一些合集视频，比如《X音素》的海选或者……我看这个。真的吗？《美国好声音》……而且我只想看他们赢的时候。
I only want to see like when they turn the chair and they come... I don't want to see any of the rejections. Yeah, I get it. Well, now talk to me about this thing, because I battle with this sometimes about exposing myself to news. Yeah, yeah. You know, like... Nudes?
我只想看他们转过椅子然后走过来的时候……我不想看任何被淘汰的片段。对，我懂。好了，现在跟我聊聊这个，因为我有时也在为了解新闻而苦恼。对，对。你知道，就像……裸照？
Exposing yourself to nudes? To nudes. Because if somebody doesn't have a great physical... Body. News, like if I can take certain news, but other news about people that are going through just... Yeah, yeah, yeah. Object hunger.
为了解裸照而苦恼？为了解裸照。因为如果某人没有绝佳的身体……身体。新闻，如果我能接受某些新闻，但关于那些正在经历……对，对，对的人的其他新闻。对象的饥饿感。
Yeah. Or, you know, kids that are sick or something like... How do you... Do you try to keep yourself... Yeah. Not the head in the sand or anything, but like... No. I just... It just kills me.
对。或者，你知道，生病的孩子之类的……你如何……你是否试着让自己……对。不是把头埋在沙子里或者别的什么，而是像……没有。我只是……这简直要了我的命。
It's too much. For me... Now, keep in mind, that's me. I think other people can really absorb it and can detach from it. You guys... Oh, I thought you were speaking for everybody. Yeah, I'm speaking for everybody. I represent the human race.
太过了。对我来说……现在请记住，这只是我。我认为其他人真的能够吸收并从中抽离。你们……哦，我还以为你在代表所有人呢。对，我在代表所有人。我代表全人类。
Sorry. But you had Bill Maron recently, and I listened to... Sure. The amount of absorbing, I think he can have that kind of detachment probably. I just can't shake it. So, like, I'll do something called... It's like the skim. It gives, like, a sense like an email.
抱歉。但你们最近请了比尔·马尔，我听了……当然。那种消化能力，我想他大概能做到那种程度的抽离。我就是无法摆脱。所以，我会做一件叫做……类似于The Skim的新闻简报。它会像一封电子邮件一样。
It'll give, like, the highlights of the day. Yeah. Right. Or no review of the news. Yeah, it's like an... Yeah, exactly. And so... Yeah, I watch David Muir every night.
它会提供一整天的重大新闻摘要。对。没错，或者没有新闻评论。对，就像一个……对，没错。所以……对，我每天晚上都看大卫·缪尔。
Oh, yeah. On ABC. But any deep dive and kind of... I just can't... Like, it's hard for me to let it go. I feel like, well, what else can I do? I mean, I'll donate or I can be charitable or whatnot. But if you get into all of the real micro detail of the suffering, it's hard.
哦，对。在ABC电视台。但任何深入挖掘和那种……我就是做不到……对我来说很难放下。我觉得，好吧，我还能做什么？我的意思是，我会捐款，或者我可以做慈善之类的。但如果你深入到痛苦的每一个微观细节里，那就太难了。
See, but that's... But see, Jason got me into a loan, so I started watching some Arctic something. Yeah. So, I started watching, like, five, six episodes. And a lot of times we would watch it while we were eating dinner, right? If we would put on a loan the next episode. Yeah. While they're skinning a squirrel.
你看，但那是……但你看，杰森让我入了《独自生存》的坑，所以我开始看一些北极题材的节目。对。所以，我开始看，大概看了五六集。很多时候我们吃晚饭时会看这个，对吧？我们会播放《独自生存》的下一集。对。当他们在剥松鼠皮的时候。
That's exactly right. The guy, like, hadn't eaten, like, one of the guys hadn't eaten, like, seven days. And he finally kills this, like, I don't know what a marsupial badger... I don't know what the hell it was. And he cooks it, chars it. He's like, oh, and he eats the whole thing. And it's just really... And he cooks the head and he eats the head.
完全正确。那家伙，比如，已经好几天没吃东西了，其中一个家伙已经有七天没吃东西了。他终于猎到了这个，我不知道那是什么有袋类动物——獾……我不知道那到底是什么鬼东西。然后他把它煮了，烤焦了。他说，哦，然后他把整只都吃光了。这真的……而且他把头也煮了吃了。
It's just so disgusting. And then, of course, he gets a stomach ache, dysentery. So, you skipped seasons. You didn't start... I know where that is. There's no way that you got there. He started with the free stuff on Netflix. I started season six.
太恶心了。然后，当然，他开始胃痛、得痢疾。所以你跳过了前几季。你没有从……我知道那是哪一季。你绝对不可能从那开始。他是从网飞上的免费内容开始看的。我从第六季开始看。
Oh, man. Yeah. He started... I did the same thing. That's what got me hooked. And then I went and I bought them all over on... What is it? History or something?
天哪。对。他开始……我也做了同样的事。就是那集让我入坑的。然后我跑去把它们全买下来了，在……什么上面？历史频道还是别的什么？
They're on Discovery Plus, man. I love Discovery Plus. So, do you watch it or do you constantly imagine what would I do in that situation? Like, how would I react to that situation? Oh, I would encourage the helicopter pilot to not even touch down. Are you kidding? It's Jason's dream. Jason's dream.
它们在探索频道Plus上，老兄。我爱探索频道Plus。所以，你是看着它，还是会不断地想象如果你处在那种情况下你会怎么做？比如，面对那种情况你会作何反应？哦，我会鼓励直升机驾驶员甚至都不要落地。你在开玩笑吗？这是杰森的梦想。杰森的梦想。
He's by himself and he doesn't have to eat. It's like the most amazing... No, no. I completely fall apart. I'm so soft. Well, you know, I can't even put together a basketball hoop. Yeah, because the contestants for Tracy, the contestants get dropped off in a helicopter, in the middle of nowhere in the helicopter.
他一个人呆着，还不用吃东西。这简直太棒了……不，不。我完全会崩溃。我太娇气了。好吧，你知道的，我甚至连一个篮球架都组装不好。对，因为《独自生存》的参赛者，参赛者会被直升机空投，扔在荒郊野岭的直升机上。
And they have a camera. Some's not with them with a camera. They've got their... They film themselves, yeah. And that's part of the battle. They talk about it a lot as they go deeper into the day count. Sometimes it's obviously the hunger, but also it's the solitude gets them and they start feeling... They do lose a lot of great water weight.
而且他们随身带着摄像机。没有人跟他们一起带着摄像机。他们有自己的……他们自己拍摄自己，对。这也是挑战的一部分。随着天数的增加，他们经常会谈到这一点。有时显然是因为饥饿，但同样也是孤独感击垮了他们，让他们开始感到……他们确实减掉了大量的水分。
I mean... You know, I'm too emotional about the animals in there. So that's why it's hard to watch that. Not the humans, just the animals. You mean that you couldn't kill the animals to eat them? Correct. What do you think's happening when you're going over to Chin Chin, man? Yeah, I know.
我的意思是……你知道的，我对里面的动物太有同情心了。所以这就是为什么看那个节目很艰难。不是对人类，只是对动物。你的意思是说你无法杀死动物来吃它们？没错。那你觉得你去金珍中餐馆时发生了什么？对，我知道。
Well, I don't want to see it. Like Jason's saying, I don't want to see it, but I'll eat it. So, head in the sand. That's terrible. How long are they out there for? Well, the longer you're out there, the closer you get to the big prize. I think the longest has been a hundred days. I may be wrong.
好吧，我不想看到它。就像杰森说的，我不想看到它，但我会吃。所以，把头埋在沙子里。这太糟糕了。他们在那里呆多久？好吧，你呆的时间越长，离大奖就越近。我想最长纪录是一百天吧。我可能记错了。
But average is probably like right around 70, 80 days, something like that. And these guys lose like... They lose like 60 pounds in three months. That sounds interesting. How did they charge their phone? Okay, well, that's a great question. They're not having... You can see that's the whole point.
但平均大概在70到80天左右，诸如此类。而且这些家伙会减掉……他们会在三个月内减掉大约60磅。听起来很有趣。他们是怎么给手机充电的？好吧，这是个好问题。他们没有……你可以看到，这就是重点。
To film themselves, idiot. To film. Like to film their stuff. Oh, now I'm an idiot. Okay. They have a pack. They have like a pack. They have like a whole pack thing.
为了自己拍摄，笨蛋。为了拍摄。比如拍摄他们自己的素材。哦，现在我成笨蛋了。好吧。他们有一个背包。他们有一个类似背包的东西。他们有一个整体的背包设备。
Well, you know what I noticed? Like they keep their food. They were like, oh, the guy's like, oh, the mice got into my food. I'm like, you have that airtight pelican box that keeps the camera equipment in. Put your fucking food in there. So they have enough battery for that whole mountain. I don't know what their battery count is, man. Okay. I don't know what's going on.
好吧，你知道我注意到什么吗？比如他们保存食物。他们会说，哦，那家伙说，哦，老鼠溜进我的食物里了。我会想，你们有那种存放摄像器材的气密鹈鹕箱。把你们他妈的食物放进去啊。所以他们有足够的电池撑过整座大山？我不知道他们的电池到底有多少电，老兄。好吧。我不知道发生了什么。
It's a hand crank battery that they've got to save enough energy for. Dear discovery. Upon watching your show, I must admit that I was concerned about the battery. And we will be right back. Thanks to Hunter Douglas for supporting Smartless. I never used to think too much about the blinds in my home. I mean, I'd sometimes, you know, adjust them in the morning, close them at night, or just kind of forget about them entirely.
那是一个手摇充电电池，他们必须留出足够的电量。亲爱的探索频道。在观看你们的节目时，我必须承认我对电池问题感到担忧。我们马上回来。感谢亨德·道格拉斯对《聪明笨蛋》栏目的大力支持。我以前从不太在意家里的百叶窗。我的意思是，有时我会，你知道的，早上调整一下，晚上拉上，或者干脆完全不管它们。
I never really understood how much window shades could actually do until I discovered Hunter Douglas. Isn't that true? Like you're like, it's like the last thing you think of are like window treatments. But Hunter Douglas offers unique shade designs that actually diffuse raw sunlight casting a beautiful glow across the room. It's beautiful. They're available in a gorgeous array of fabrics and colors that create incredible style and the perfect finishing touch to any room decor.
我以前从不真正理解窗帘实际上能发挥多大作用，直到我发现了亨德·道格拉斯。难道不是吗？就像你会觉得，窗饰简直是你想到的最后一件事。但亨德·道格拉斯提供了独特的窗帘设计，能够真正柔化直射的阳光，在房间里投射出美丽的光晕。太美了。它们有各种华丽的面料和颜色可供选择，能够营造出令人惊叹的风格，并为任何房间装饰带来完美的点睛之笔。
The best part about Hunter Douglas is their PowerView automated shade technology. PowerView allows you to schedule your shades to automatically adjust to their perfect positions throughout the day. How cool is that? From letting in light slowly as you awake to adjusting to block the hot midday sun or raising just in time for a perfect sunset. Innovative shade designs from Hunter Douglas make everyday living more beautiful, comfortable, and convenient. I love Hunter Douglas because of all the different things.
亨德·道格拉斯最棒的地方在于他们的PowerView自动化窗帘技术。PowerView允许你预设窗帘，让它们在一天中自动调整到最完美的位置。这有多酷？从你醒来时让阳光缓缓照进房间，到调整以阻挡正午炽热的阳光，或者正好在完美的日落时分升起。亨德·道格拉斯的创新窗帘设计让日常生活更加美好、舒适和便捷。我喜欢亨德·道格拉斯是因为它有各种各样的选择。
They have roller shades. They have Roman shades. They have like, you know, vertical blind. They have anything, any kind of shade or window covering, they have it. I'm personally like, you know, like a good wood shutter. You know, I just think it looks classy. And that the one I prefer the most is Heritance. It's just kind of like, you know, my style, my color, my aesthetic, all that kind of stuff.
他们有卷帘。他们有罗马帘。他们还有，你知道的，垂直百叶窗。他们应有尽有，任何类型的窗帘或窗饰，他们都有。就我个人而言，你知道的，我喜欢优质的木质百叶窗。你知道，我只是觉得它看起来很有档次。我最偏爱的是赫里恩斯（Heritance）系列。它有点像是，你知道的，我的风格、我的色彩、我的审美，所有这些东西。
And right now, for a limited time, you can take advantage of special rebate savings of $100 or more on some of Hunter Douglas's most popular styles offered on December 5th. So visit hunterdouglas.com slash smartlist today for details and take advantage of special rebate savings of $100 or more. That's hunterdouglas.com slash smartlist. Smartlist gets support from FanDuel. Football season is underway, so now is the perfect time to download FanDuel, America's number one sports book.
现在，在限时优惠期间，您可以享受100美元或更多的特别返利优惠，适用于亨德·道格拉斯在12月5日推出的几款最受欢迎的风格。所以今天就访问hunterdouglas.com/smartless了解详情，并享受100美元或更多的特别返利优惠。网址是 hunterdouglas.com/smartless。《聪明笨蛋》得到了FanDuel的支持。足球赛季正在进行中，现在是下载美国第一体育博彩公司FanDuel的最佳时机。
Because right now, new customers get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. That's free bets back if your first bet doesn't win. Just sign up with promo code smartlist. FanDuel, if you don't know, has all your favorite bets from the money line to point spreads to player props. You can combine your bets for a chance at a bigger payout with a same game parlay. With live betting, you'll get updated odds on games that have already started. The app is safe, secure, and super easy to use. Get your winnings paid fast.
因为现在，新用户可以享受高达1000美元的零风险首注优惠。如果你的第一注没有赢，将获得免费投注返还。只需使用促销代码 smartless 注册即可。如果你还不知道，FanDuel拥有你所有最喜欢的投注项目，从独赢盘到让分盘再到球员道具盘。你可以将多个投注组合在一起，通过同场连串过关获得赢得更高奖金的机会。通过实时投注，你可以获得已经开始的比赛的最新赔率。该app安全、可靠且超级易用。让你的赢利快速到账。
So sign up today with promo code smartlist for your no sweat first bet. Make every moment more this season with FanDuel, official sportsbook partner of the NFL. And believe it or not, I'm actually really, really into football. I love it. And I've been watching almost every game this year. And so I'm really excited to do a deep dive into FanDuel. 21 plus exclusions apply. C show notes for full disclaimer.
所以今天就使用促销代码 smartless 注册，享受你的零风险首注吧。在这个赛季与NFL官方体育博彩合作伙伴FanDuel一起让每一个时刻都更加精彩。信不信由你，我其实真的、真的超级喜欢足球。我太爱它了。今年我几乎看了每一场比赛。所以我非常兴奋能深入了解FanDuel。21岁及以上适用除外条款。完整免责声明请参阅节目说明。
Now a word from our sponsor, better help. Hey guys, I know I talk a lot about therapy, mental health. I think it's really, really important. I think it's important to address it even if you're scared to address it. And also, you know, I've been going through like a pretty rough time lately and therapy has really, really helped me get through it. It can be tough to train your brain to stay in problem solving mode when faced with a challenge in life. But when you learn how to find your own solutions, there's no better feeling. Trust me.
现在由我们的赞助商BetterHelp带来一段寄语。嘿，伙计们，我知道我经常谈论心理治疗和心理健康。我认为这真的、真的很重要。我认为即使你害怕面对它，去正视它也很重要。而且，你知道的，我最近经历了一段相当艰难的时期，心理治疗真的、真的帮我度过了难关。当面对生活中的挑战时，训练你的大脑保持解决问题的模式可能会很艰难。但是当你学会如何寻找自己的解决方案时，没有比这更好的感觉了。相信我。
A therapist can help you become a better problem solver, making it easier to accomplish your goals, no matter how big or small. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, accessible, affordable, and entirely online. Get matched with a therapist after filling out a brief survey and switch therapists at any time. I know for some people, if you're new to therapy, it can be kind of like, I don't know, embarrassing or feel like, you know, you're weak or something. But it's actually the complete opposite of both of those. Like I started going to therapy and now I brag about it because of the benefits of it. And because I'm telling you, being on the other side of it, I'm telling you, it is so good for you.
治疗师可以帮助你成为一个更好的问题解决者，让你更容易实现目标，无论目标有多大或多小。如果你正在考虑尝试心理治疗，BetterHelp是一个绝佳的选择。它很方便、易于获取、价格实惠且完全在线。在填写一份简短的问卷后，就能与匹配的治疗师开始交流，并且可以随时更换治疗师。我知道对某些人来说，如果你是心理治疗的新手，可能会觉得有点，怎么说呢，尴尬，或者觉得好像自己很软弱什么的。但实际上它与这两者完全相反。就像我开始去看心理治疗，现在我甚至会因为它的好处而到处炫耀。而且我告诉你，身处其中经历过之后，我向你保证，它对你真的太有益了。
And you feel better. And that's what it's all about. When you want to be a better problem solver, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's better, H-E-L-P.com slash smartlist. Back to the show. Tony, what is the, you've done like a laundry list of so many movies. I've got it here in front of me, Sean, if you're interested.
你会感觉好多了。这才是最重要的。当你想要成为一个更好的问题解决者时，心理治疗能帮你实现。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受9折优惠。网址是 better，H-E-L-P.com/smartless。回到节目。托尼，你拍过什么，你拍过的电影简直是一长串。肖恩，如果你感兴趣的话，我这儿正列着呢。
What is one of like, other than Veep and Arrested, of course, those two stand out. What's one of the best experiences you've had like on a set or with another actor and who was that? And like what are, like if somebody said pinpoint the highlight other than Arrested and Veep, because we all know how great and special those were. Is there like a moment or a person that really kind of, wow, that totally inspired you or blew it away? Unless it's an Arrested story involving me, good. I really side note, I mean, it was, Arrested was so crazy, fun and wild and overwhelming and all that stuff. But, Anne Veep, but aside from that, I would say I did this movie called Nine Days with this director, Ed Sonoda.
除了《副总统》和《发展受阻》之外，当然，这两部脱颖而出，还有什么。你在片场或与其他演员合作过最好的经历之一是什么？那是谁？还有，如果有谁说请指出除了《发展受阻》和《副总统》之外的高光时刻，因为我们都知道这两部剧有多棒、多特别。有没有哪个瞬间或某个人真的让你觉得，哇，那彻底启发了你或者惊艳了你？除非是个涉及我的《发展受阻》的故事，那还好。说实话，顺便提一句，这真是，《发展受阻》太疯狂、太有趣、太狂野、太震撼了，所有这些。还有《副总统》，但除此之外，我要说我拍过一部叫《九天》的电影，导演是埃德·索诺达。
And it's, it was such a beautiful movie and he was so good at what he did and so calm and the movie is so beautiful. And that's one of those that really, I think about a lot. And I just did Being in the Riccardo's with Nicole, Kim and Javier Bardin and watching them really boldly take over those iconic roles. That was really cool to be on the sidelines and watch that, really cool. And tell me, what are you doing right now? You said you're doing a show over on Discovery Plus. That's Disney Plus. It's a mysterious Benedict society.
这是一部非常美丽的电影，他在自己的工作上太优秀了，而且非常冷静，电影拍得美极了。那是那种我经常会回想起的电影。我刚和妮可·基德曼以及哈维尔·巴登一起拍了《里卡多一家》，看着他们极其大胆地接演那些标志性的角色。能在场边旁观这一切真的很酷，太酷了。告诉我，你现在在忙什么？你刚才说你在探索频道Plus上拍了一部剧。那是迪士尼+。那是《神秘代号：贝尼迪克特学会》。
It's based on a children's series. And that's, here I'm doing a movie with my friend Seth Worley called Sketch, but I did that and that's, it's based on this series by a guy named Trent Stewart who wrote the books. And it's just a beautiful, beautiful story. And I get to play twins. Do you really? You do? Yeah, I get to play twins on the show. An evil one and a good one?
它是根据一套儿童系列小说改编的。这就是，我在和我朋友塞思·沃利拍一部叫《素描》的电影，但我拍过那个，它是根据一个叫特伦特·斯图尔特的人写的书改编的。这真是一个美丽、美丽的故事。而且我在里面扮演双胞胎。真的吗？你演双胞胎？对。对，我在剧里演双胞胎。一个坏的和一个好的？
He's complicated, but he's like, yeah, the good one and like a one that's had a lot of trauma. Like a soap opera. Tell me about that because there are certain characters that you would not play. Am I right? I don't know if I think, if I'm honest, I think I probably would have said that in the past, like I would have drawn a line, but until I hear the story, I don't know if I can draw a line of like what I wouldn't play, you know, because it's, would it be based on whether it's gratuitous or unredemptive or, you know, like, could you play a serial murder? Yeah, I could. You answered that really fast.
他很复杂，但就像是，对，一个好的，还有一个经历过很多创伤的。就像肥皂剧一样。跟我聊聊这个，因为有些角色是你绝对不会去演的。我说的对吗？我不知道，如果老实说，我想我过去可能会这么说，比如我会画一条红线，但在我听到故事之前，我不知道自己能不能对不演什么划清界限，你知道吗，因为这会取决于它是无意义的暴力、无法救赎的，还是……你知道的，比如，你能演一个连环杀手吗？对，我能。你回答得真快。
But he's gonna hurt a gold. He's gonna hurt a gold. No, I could, but it's like, and even if it's not redemptive, I mean, it's an, I mean, you look at Veep, for instance, she wasn't a serial killer, but you see that equation of this is what happens when you live a life of narcissism and never giving away. You end in isolation and you end up, you know, bitter. Right. And so that's, that wouldn't be considered redemptive, but it's what a, what a great story to show that, yeah, show that equation. Yeah. Right, right, right.
但他会伤害一个黄金。他会伤害一个黄金。不，我能，但就像，即使它不是可救赎的，我的意思是，你看《副总统》，举个例子，她不是一个连环杀手，但你可以看到那种因果关系，这就是当你过着自恋、从不付出的人生时会发生的事。你的结局会是孤立无援，最后变得痛苦不堪。没错。所以那不会被认为是可救赎的，但这是一个多么棒的故事，能展现出这种……是的，展现出这种因果关系。没错，没错，没错。
What are the, what are the, I mean, you have done, you're so known and obviously celebrated and you've won awards for your comedy. Oh, that's very nice. Well, it's true. And, and you, you've, you've done these sort of, you know, great icon, play these great iconic characters, comedic characters. Do you, is there part of you that's like, okay, I really want to do, because we asked this, we talked about this when we have people on the show all the time. Like, do you have this thing in your sights of like, I want to do a great this, like a great dramatic role that really shows this. Is that something that kind of burns inside you? Uh, if I'm honest, I think when I was younger, I was kind of, I would say that, but I think I had different motivations of wanting to, I don't know,
有什么是，有什么是——我的意思是，你演过，你太知名了，显然备受赞誉，而且你因为喜剧赢得了奖项。哦，太客气了。好吧，这是事实。而且，你，你演过这些，你知道的，伟大的标志性角色，扮演过这些伟大的标志性喜剧角色。你，你内心深处有没有一部分会觉得，好吧，我真的很想去演——因为我们问过这个，我们在节目里经常和嘉宾探讨这个问题。比如，你的目标里有没有这样一种想法：我想演一个这样的大角色，比如一个真正展现这一点的伟大正剧角色？这是一种在你内心熊熊燃烧的渴望吗？呃，老实说，我觉得我年轻的时候可能会这么说，但我认为我当时有不同的动机想去，我不知道……
get attention or I don't know what it was. But now I think it's, I don't know if you guys feel this way, but the older you get things just get a little simpler. And it's like, and so it's not necessarily about those big markers. It's about, I would, I would obviously love, I love working, but I like it's so much more about relationships and so much more about connecting and who you are and set. But I mean, obviously good stories and you want to, I want to be careful as I really believe. The quality of the work experience. Yeah. But that's, that's really the stuff that is, has longevity to it.
吸引注意，或者我也不知道那是什么。但现在我觉得，我不知道你们大家有没有这种感觉，人越老，事情反而变得越简单。这就好像，所以这不一定关乎那些重大的里程碑。而是关于——我当然很乐意，我热爱工作，但我更看重的是人际关系，是彼此的连接，你是谁，以及在片场。但我的意思是，显然需要好故事，而且你想——我得谨慎一点，因为我真的相信。工作体验的质量。是的。但那才是真正具有长久生命力的东西。
I mean, the work obviously is good, but it's like, how you impact people on set and all that stuff. I don't know. That's kind of, as I get older, that's where you see the power in that. I feel, I feel you on that. And like you guys, I think it's like so, I mean, your podcast is so fun and just how you guys are with each other and the laughing and just like, and even like you touring. I mean, that's like, there's so much, so much beautiful, like life giving power to that. Tony, I gotta tell you, it's so, it's so crazy. I mean, you know us, it's so weird.
我的意思是，工作本身当然很好，但关键在于你如何在片场影响他人，诸如此类的事情。我不知道。随着年龄增长，你会从那种事情中看到力量。我能理解你的感受。就像你们一样，我觉得——也就是说，你们的播客太有趣了，你们相处的方式、笑声、还有甚至是你们的巡演。我的意思是，那里面包含着巨大的、赋予生命的能量。托尼，我得告诉你，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，你了解我们，这太奇妙了。
But it's like, I think it's so fun and just like, you can see that it gives you life. You know, like that's like, as you get older, like that's the shit that matters. And it did come from that pure place that you're talking about where we had, we had no idea, dream or goal about the end result. It was all about, well, how can the three of us stay better in touch during COVID? You know, and so we just kind of got a little bit more official, you know. Yeah. And but the element that you have of the surprise, because like there's two of you that are coming in with an energy of like what's coming. Right.
但这就像，我觉得这太有趣了，而且你能看出它给了你生命力。你知道的，就好像随着年龄增长，那才是真正重要的东西。而且它确实源于你所说的那个纯粹的起点，当时我们对最终结果没有任何概念、梦想或目标。一切都只是为了：我们三个人怎么能在疫情期间更好地保持联系？你知道的，所以我们就把它变得稍微正式了一点。是的。但你们身上有一种惊喜的元素，因为你们俩进门时都带着一种“接下来会发生什么”的能量。没错。
And it's like, that provides that, ooh, what gift are we going to get today? And not as like to build up arrested. But that's how I did feel like also unarrested, like we never, ever knew. The whole show was just one big surprise. We never knew what Mitch was going to throw at us. And it gives you this like, it doesn't fit any formula. It's always the surprise. I remember Tony after, between those seasons one and two, and we were all in, we're at a hotel in Century City.
这就带来了一种“哦，我们今天会得到什么礼物呢？”的感觉。并不是为了营造《发展受阻》的氛围。但《发展受阻》给我的感觉确实也是这样的，我们永远、永远都猜不到。整部剧就是一个巨大的惊喜。我们永远不知道米奇会给我们抛出什么梗。它带给你这种感觉，它不符合任何公式，永远都是惊喜。我记得托尼在第一季和第二季之间，我们全都在——我们在世纪城的某个酒店里。
And we just found out that we won those that we got nominated for. Do you remember that we were doing like the press that morning early? All of us. And I don't. Okay. You and I were staying at that hotel right there in Century City. I remember this. And then Jason, you came over the night before.
我们刚得知我们赢了——我们获得了提名。你还记得那天一大早我们在做媒体采访吗？我们所有人。我不记得了。好吧。你和我当时就住在世纪城的那家酒店里。我记得这件事。然后杰森，你前天晚上过来了。
And then early that morning we went and did a bunch of press. And that's when we found out that we had won. Not won, but we got all these nominations for the show. And I remember, so we're downstairs. We're really, really happy. And then Tony, we were talking to Mitch and stuff. And then we're going to walk back. And you go, what's going to go, well, Mitch just told me that I'm going to lose my hand to a seal.
然后那天一早我们去做了很多媒体采访。也就是在那时我们得知我们获奖了。不是获奖，而是我们为这部剧获得了所有这些提名。我记得，我们在楼下。我们真的、真的很高兴。然后托尼，我们跟米奇他们聊了聊。接着我们要走回去，然后你说，你将要——哦，米奇刚刚告诉我，我的手要被海豹咬掉了。
And I remember, and I was like, for the whole, he's like, yeah, I guess for the whole season. Yeah, I was actually pretty, I was pretty upset about it. Now, since you were talking about it, I remember now a picture of us down there. Yeah. We were down there and it was, I remember that from a picture. But yeah, I remember when he told me that. So you just said to Mitch, he said, so bitch, so we're going to do another season. No, I had an idea.
我记得，当时我就想，整个——他说，对，我猜整个季度都是这样。是的，其实我当时挺郁闷的。现在既然你提起了，我想起了一张我们在那儿的照片。是的。我们在那儿，从一张照片里我还记得这事。不过是的，我记得他当时是怎么告诉我这件事的。所以你当时对米奇说，你对米奇说，我们要拍第二季了？不，我当时有个想法。
I think I had an idea, a really bad idea. I think I might have even said, hey, what if like, what if like Buster's on like dancing with the stars or something like that? Or something just really out there. And he's like, yeah, I'm thinking about having a seal bite off your hand. And I was like, and I just, I didn't even know how to compute it. What is the, have you, did you ever have like a massive injury on that or VP or anything that's like, anything go absolutely chaotic and hurt yourself? Oh, for real. He means for real.
我想我当时有个想法，一个非常糟糕的想法。我想我甚至可能说过：“嘿，如果——如果巴斯特去参加《与星共舞》之类的节目会怎么样？”或者类似这种非常离谱的点子。然后他说：“我在考虑让一只海豹咬掉你的手。”我就想，我当时甚至不知道该怎么去理解这句话。你在那上面有没有受过什么重伤，维尔（VP），或者别的什么？有没有经历过完全失控然后受伤的情况？哦，认真的吗？他指的是认真的。
Oh, for real. Oh, for real. You got to keep your knees bent with Sean. His, his questions. This guy is a, is a real man. Oh yeah. Yeah. I love them.
哦，认真的。哦，认真的。跟肖恩在一起你得随时弯着膝盖。他的问题。这家伙是个——是个狠角色。哦，是的。是的。我喜欢他们。
Well, it's a surprise. These are award nominated question, question here. Sean. Did I, I don't think so. I don't think so. And then start thinking about your favorite theater story. Yeah. Crazy ever happened on stage, but, but let's hear about anything ever, you ever hurt yourself, Tony?
好吧，这算是一个惊喜。这些都是获得大奖提名的好问题，肖恩。我有吗？我不这么觉得。我不这么觉得。然后开始回想你最喜欢的戏剧故事。是的。舞台上发生过什么疯狂的事吗？不过，让我们听听有没有受过伤的经历，托尼？
No, but I do remember. He's the best. Go ahead, Tony. Hey, Tony, any, any, any terrible memories you want to read? I'm trying to talk about anything other than arrest and develop. I know. I'm sorry, Sean. This is, this is.
没有，但我确实记得。他太棒了。说吧，托尼。嘿，托尼，有什么——有什么你想吐槽的可怕回忆吗？我正想聊点《发展受阻》以外的话题呢。我知道。对不起，肖恩。这、这。
But you know, it's not a terrible question. Tony, have you ever broken a bone? Honestly. No, that's a real question. I have. How'd you do that? I stubbed my toe. Oh, bless it.
但你知道，这不是个糟糕的问题。托尼，你骨折过吗？说实话。没有，这倒是个正经问题。我有过。你怎么弄的？我脚趾踢到东西了。哦，天哪。
Walk us through that. Was it going for it? Were you going for peepees in the middle of the night? No, I was stepping over my dog door. Oh, are you okay? Say it again. I was stepping over. I was stepping over my dog door.
跟我们讲讲当时的情形。是拼过头了吗？你是不是大半夜起来上厕所？没有，我当时正跨过我的狗门。哦，你没事吧？再说一遍。我当时在跨过——我当时在跨过我的狗门。
You can't step over a dog door. You'd go into the. Well, no, because it was locked to keep the dogs in. And then I stepped over and intripped and, and so on. Well, dog gate. Well, dog gate. Well, dog gate. Yeah.
你不能跨过狗门。你会走进——好吧，没有，因为它锁着是为了把狗关在里面。然后我跨过去时绊倒了，然后就这样。好吧，是狗栏。好吧，狗栏。好吧，狗栏。对。
Yes. I'm sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
是的。对不起。对。对。对。对。好吧。
All right. That's understandable. Any theater stories? Any, any horrible. Any horrible theater stories? Yeah. Yeah. Well, you did that.
好吧。这可以理解。有什么戏剧故事吗？有什么可怕的——有什么可怕的戏剧故事吗？对。对。好吧，你演过那个，你跟莫莉演过那部戏，对吧，肖恩？莫莉·香农。对。对。不过那是两年前的事了。我在旧金山的ACT剧院演过一个人的独角戏，剧名叫威利写的《醒醒》（Wakey Wakey）。
Yeah. You did that play with Molly, didn't you, Sean? Molly Shannon. Yeah. Yeah. But I did two years ago. I did a one man play in San Francisco at ACT and a call Wakey Wakey by Willie.
不。我当时吓坏了，生怕自己忘词。我记得每天晚上。是的。独角戏。没人能帮衬。是的。就感觉自己会把所有东西都忘光。
No. And I was so petrified that I was going to forget a line. And I remember every night. Yeah. One man show. You got no help. Yeah. Just feeling like I was going to forget everything.
然后靠着上帝的恩典，我——我谢天谢地总是有人在台下以防万一。但我——我提前大约六个月就开始背台词了，因为我太慌了，怕自己忘词。但这让我想起了，杰森，我永远不会忘记在片场的情形，因为对于台词，我必须——我必须花点时间去消化它们。
And then by the grace of God, I just, I, I always had thankfully someone was offset in case I did. But I, but I started memorizing like six months before because I was so panicked. I was going to forget a line. But that makes me think, Jason, I'll never forget being on set because I, with lines, I have to, I have to kind of take some time with them to absorb.
我记得你都是在当天早上才读剧本，然后就把词记住了。是这样吗？就好像你只是扫了一眼页面。是的。他有一种疯狂的——我的大脑只为一件事运转，那就是威利真的——好吧，威尔把玛丽·卢·亨娜（Mary Lou Henner）那些日期记忆法都掌握了，而且他还
I remember you reading the script the morning of and then getting them. Is that correct? Like you would just skim the page. Yeah. He's like a crazy, he has a crazy. My brain works for one thing and it's that Willie's really, well, Will's got the Mary Lou Henner dates stuff down and also
能记住很多东西。他能记住台词。所以他的一颗大脑有两个用途。而我只有一颗。我的意思是，那部剧真的教会了我很多，对我来说基础深厚。那部剧让我学到了很多经验，这真的很棒。
he can remember a lot. He can remember lines. So he's got two uses first brain. I only have the one. I mean, I was, that show really taught me was pretty foundational for me. I'm just kind of a lot of lessons from that show for me, which is great.
我懂你。我也是。是的。我想，对于我们的听众来说，你得明白，对于我们和肖恩来说——你刚才说，你有点在说，咱们别聊《发展受阻》了。哦，不，不。我没有，但首先那是一个如此具有转折意义的时刻，如果你听到我们在
I'm with you. Me too. Yeah. I think, and I think for our listener, you have to understand for us and Sean, you're saying, and you're sort of saying, let's not talk about the rest of two months. Oh, no, no. I'm, but first it was such a seminal moment and if you hear us
谈论自己或者别的什么，我们只是在分享爱，因为我们看到托尼时感到无比快乐和兴奋，这勾起了我们太多的回忆，那些来自我们生活中的、非常重要且重大的回忆。我们有过一段共同的人生经历，那是一件大事。我们过去在一起的时间甚至超过了跟自己家人在一起的时间。只是我们后来没能再那样聚在一起了。
making it about ourselves or whatever, we're just sharing love because we're so happy and giddy to see Tony and it, and it brings up so many memories that are really important, big memories from our lives. And we had this shared experience in our life that was a really big thing. And we used to spend more time together than our own families. And we just haven't been able to do that.
我知道。我喜欢听你们聊这些。真的。是的。这也是——这也是，我确信你能感同身受，肖恩。这也是，当你回想起那个时期。我的意思是，差不多——你知道，将近20年前。而且很难不为自己当时——你知道的——如何对某些事情做出反应而感到尴尬，因为当时我处于一种极其不知所措的状态。幸好，我当时在演一个非常不知所措的角色。所以这倒挺契合的。但就像，我当时知道，我从来没有去过摄影棚，我从来没有——我什么都不知道，我就是什么都不知道。我以前从来没有在白天获得过那么多的免费食物供应。
I know. I love hearing about it. I really do. Yeah. It's also like, it's also, I'm sure you can relate to this shot. It's also, you think back to that time. I mean, almost, you know, almost 20 years ago. And it's hard not to be embarrassed of kind of how, you know, I
然后我就像——什么都理不清，你知道的，我就会到处走走，还有你自己的停车位。是的。还有，是的，我自己的停车位，就只是为了——那种感觉就像，你在成长过程中赋予了某样东西太多的分量，比如那个情景喜剧，那种分量。然后当你真正得到了它，你就会想：为什么我还是这么焦虑？
would react to certain things or because I was in this very overwhelmed state. Thankfully, I was playing a very overwhelmed character. So that kind of worked. But just like, I knew, I had never been on a studio a lot. I had never, I didn't know, I just didn't know anything. I didn't ever have that much free food offered to me during the day.
为什么我——我以为我的感觉会不一样。我当时，而这正是因为那个。好吧，为什么——为什么你还是会觉得焦虑？仅仅是因为你觉得：既然我现在拥有了它。现在有了必须拿得出表现的压力？你是这个意思吗？嗯，我觉得，这是几方面原因造成的（你知道的，感谢心理治疗），但我觉得
And I was just like, what's everything, nothing was computing, you know, and I would just walk around and your own parking space. Yeah. And yeah, my own parking space, just to kind of, and that thing of like, you give something so much weight growing up of like, that sitcom, that weight. And then when you get it, you're like, why am I still anxious?
我在人生的大部分时间里其实并没有真正活在当下。我觉得我从来没有真正地——我总是向前看，想着：好吧，那个要来了。那个情景喜剧要来了。那个大事要来了。是的。然后我得到了它，我不得不感叹：哦，糟糕。因为问题在于，如果你活在当下，如果你身处
Why am I, I thought I was going to feel differently. I was, and it's just from that. Well, why, why, why did you feel still feel anxious just because you felt then now that I have it. Now there's pressure to, now to deliver. Is that what you mean? Well, I think there's, it's a few things and, you know, thank God for therapy, but it's like, I really don't think
那个时代，那么当你得到某种东西时，它就会顺其自然地展开，而不是背负着所有这些沉重的包袱。我已经说过好几次了，如果任何人听过我唠叨的话，我向你们道歉，但这就是那个道理：如果你没有在当下练习知足，那么当你得到你想要的东西时，你也不会感到知足。我觉得我在《发展受阻》剧组时真的深深体会到了这一点。
I was very present for most of my life. I don't think I'd never really, I would always be looking ahead of like, well, that's coming. That sitcom's coming. That big thing's coming. Yeah. And then I got it and I had to go, oh crap. I, because the thing is, if you're present and if you're
是的。我觉得有一个非常相似的观点，我前几天还跟别人聊过这个。你不能——我非常努力地去做到这一点，虽然不够完美。我做得并不完美，我没有完美地执行它，但我真的在思考这样一个理念：我不能受制于环境，这意味着我的快乐不能系于某种
in that time, then when you get something, it's just kind of, you know, it just kind of unfolds rather than carry this, all this weight. And I've said this several times and I apologize if anybody has heard me babble about it, but it's that whole thing of like, if you're not practicing contentment where you are, you're not going to be content when you get what you want. And I think that really hit me on arrested, you know.
外在的东西，因为那样的话，你可就惨了，对吧？因为生活会起起落落，没有什么是直线发展的，你不能——如果我受制于其他事物，我就必须——这不像是“眼见为实，我看到了才会相信”，你知道的，这几乎就像是我必须先相信，然后才能看到。我的快乐必须源自内心，而且不管怎样，不管我外在发生什么，它都——
Yeah. I think that there's a very similar, I was talking about this with somebody the other day. You can't be, I try really hard and not perfectly. I don't do it. I don't execute it perfectly, but I really think about this idea that I can't be at the effective circumstances and, and meaning that my happiness can't be pegged to something
对。我觉得有一个非常相似的，我前几天还跟别人聊过这个。你不能，我非常努力地尝试，虽然做不到完美。我没做到。我没有完美执行，但我真的在思考这个想法，即我不能受制于环境，这意味着我的快乐不能系于某些
outside because then it's, you're in for a shit, right? Cause it's going to go up and down and nothing's in a straight line and you can't, if I'm at the effect of other things, I have to, it's not like I'll see it, you know, I'll believe it when I'll see it, you know, it's almost like I got to believe it and then I'll see it. My happiness has to come from here and, and it doesn't matter if I actually, whatever happens outside of me is going to
外界的事物上，因为如果是那样的话，你就惨了，对吧？因为情况会上下起伏，没有什么是直线发展的，你不能，如果我受制于其他事物，我必须，这不像是“眼见为实”，你知道的，我得先相信，然后才能看到。我的快乐必须源自这里，不管怎样，无论我外部发生什么
happen. Well, how do you, how do you guys avoid falling into complacency or being more comfortable than is healthy with normalcy or mediocrity? Like in other words, how do you, how do you balance contentment and also staying ambitious and driven and, and have goals and prepare for future and balance. I think, which is, you know, the easy, how do you, how do you
发生。嗯，你们怎么，你们怎么避免陷入自满，或者对现状或平庸产生不健康的过度舒适感？换句话说，你们怎么，你们怎么在保持满足感的同时，又保持雄心勃勃、积极进取，有目标，为未来做准备，并平衡好这两者。我觉得，这其实是，你知道，简单，你怎么，你怎么
know, how do you know what it is until you have the, the, the clarity of retrospection, right? Yeah. And I think, I think that's a great question because I'm glad you really glad you asked, cause it's not that I'm not, it's not that ambition or dreaming is wrong at all. In our business, I feel like there's a subliminal messaging of like, you will have value when this happens.
知道，在没有回首过去的清晰视角之前，你怎么能知道那是什么，对吧？是的。而且我觉得，我觉得这是一个很好的问题，因为我很高兴，真的很高兴你问了这个问题，因为并不是说我没有，并不是说雄心壮志或做梦是错的。在我们的行业里，我觉得有一种潜移默化的信息，好像在说：当这件事情发生时，你才是有价值的。
You will have value if this big thing comes into your life. And the truth is my value before any of this happens, the exact same as my value now, your value when all, it's your value doesn't change. And so I think with ambition, many times what I did is associated my value to getting that. Yeah. Your outward value as opposed to your internal value.
如果这件大事降临到你的生活，你才是有价值的。但事实是，在这一切发生之前，我的价值和现在的价值完全一样，当这一切发生时，你的价值……你的价值并没有改变。所以我觉得对于雄心，很多时候我所做的是把我的价值和得到那个东西联系起来。是的。你外在的价值，而不是你的内在价值。
No, I connected it like my, without knowing it, my internal value, I can go back to that reunion and be like, Hey, look what you make, you know, whatever. But it's like, my internal value would be better if I got that stuff. When in actuality, that internal value is the exact same. Yeah, of course. But that's not the message you hear.
不，我把它们连接起来，在不知不觉中，我的内在价值……我可以回到那次同学聚会上，心想：“嘿，看看你取得了什么成就，你知道的，诸如此类。”但这就好像，如果我得到了那些东西，我的内在价值就会更高。而实际上，那个内在价值是完全一样的。是的，当然。但这不是你听到的信息。
I think in the business. Does that make sense? Yeah, for sure. No, certainly because you get what, and it's easy to fall into, it's a trap. You can fall into it very easily. And it's very easy to again, sort of peg your, your, your value, if you will, that let's say,
我觉得在这个行业里是这样的。这说得通吗？是的，当然。不，当然如此，因为你得到了什么，而且很容易陷入其中，这是一个陷阱。你很容易就会陷入其中。而且很容易再次把你的，你的，你的价值，如果你愿意的话，比方说，
I'll say happiness to, to outside things. Yeah. And you're also in this business, you're also, you're constantly being asked like, what's next? You know, what's next for you? Which is a great question. Which is a great question. But you kind of don't go up to a dentist and say, what's next?
我会把幸福寄托在外在事物上。是的。而且在这个行业里，你还经常被问到：“接下来是什么？”你知道的，“接下来你有什么打算？”这是一个很好的问题。这也是一个很好的问题。但你不会走到一个牙医面前问他：“接下来是什么？”
You know, true, but this is a unique, this business is unique in that, at least for actors and also directors and I guess anybody, it's very all a cart. Like you don't have one job that lasts 30, 40 years like a dentist would, it is sort of you, you're constantly getting hired and fired because the jobs come to an end. So it is a natural question, but it is an annoying one to have to manage.
你知道，确实如此，但这很独特，这个行业很独特的地方在于，至少对演员、导演以及我想对任何人来说，它都非常像点菜。就像你没有一份能干30、40年的工作，不像牙医那样，你基本上是不断地被雇佣和解雇，因为工作总会结束。所以这是一个很自然的问题，但要应付它又确实让人有点烦。
But then sometimes when you do a show, when you do a show, it becomes much more sort of a pre-feaks, you know? Yeah. And I wouldn't even say it. I wouldn't say it. I wouldn't say annoying because I, I didn't, I didn't mean that it's not annoying, but it's, it's a challenge for me to not always be looking to next.
但有时候当你演一部剧，当你演一部剧时，它会变得更像是某种既定事物，你知道吗？是的。我甚至不会这么说。我不会这么说。我不会说它烦人，因为我，我不是那个意思，它倒不烦人，但对我来说，挑战在于不要总是把目光投向下一步。
You know, it's like that's easy to fall into that when, yeah, it is piecemeal together. Absolutely. Is Loi at all interested in going into this business? Um, she is, uh, not if, no, she's at, but she did just get cast in a steel magnolias at her school and she's going to be, yeah, she's going to, she's excited to do that. And so, uh, but she wants to, I mean, this could change,
你知道的，当工作，是的，确实是东拼西凑起来的时候，很容易陷入这种状态。绝对是的。罗伊对进入这行有一点兴趣吗？嗯，她有，呃，如果没有……不，她有，但她最近刚刚在学校的《钢木兰》里获得了一个角色，她将要……是的，她很高兴能去演这个。所以，呃，但她想，我的意思是，这可能会改变，
but she really is interested in education. Oh, cool. Yeah. Would you, would you encourage her in this business if she did go that direction? I, I would be lying if I didn't have, uh, probably an anxiety attached to it and have to do a couple more therapy lessons. But, um, I, you know, it's that whole thing of like,
但她确实对教育很感兴趣。哦，酷。是的。如果她真的朝这个方向发展，你会鼓励她进入这行吗？如果我说我对这件事没有产生焦虑，并且不需要再去上几节心理治疗课，那我就是在撒谎。但是，呃，你知道的，就是那种整件事，
you never want to dictate your child's, you know, wrath. So I would have to just, I would, I would be curious. That's the thing. Like there's one thing that we're with parenting is, is rather than being reactive, be curious and just, you know, be like, Oh, well, cause what I want to do is react and be like, well, let me teach you these lessons. Right.
你永远不想主导你孩子的，你知道的，人生方向。所以我只能保持好奇心。就是这样。我们在育儿方面的一点是，与其做出反应，不如保持好奇，然后，你知道的，心想：“哦，好吧，因为我想做的是立刻反应，然后说：‘好吧，让我来教你这些道理吧。’”对吧。
And I just need to kind of shut up and just listen. Yeah. Yeah. I haven't seen her since she was, I know six maybe or something like that. You guys though made me laugh so hard. Like it is, uh, there's a, I don't know if you guys watch Sean, don't feel bad cause I don't watch the episodes myself much,
而我只需要闭上嘴，好好听着就行了。是的。是的。我从她六岁左右或者类似的时候起就没见过她了，你知道的。不过你们真的让我笑得太厉害了。就像，呃，有一个，我不知道你们看不看……肖恩，别觉得不好意思，因为我自己也不怎么看这些剧集，
but I do every now and then we'll watch the blooper reels that they gave us because that's this, that's the stuff that I remember. I'll watch those. And there's a, there's one blooper of Will and I coming in and Liza's in the room and we have our robes on and we couldn't even get any two words out and just busted, but it was such a organic breakdown that it just gives me so much joy to see
但我确实每隔一段时间会看一下他们给我们的NG花絮集，因为那就是，那是我记住的东西。我会看那些。其中有一个NG镜头是威尔和我走进来，莉莎也在房间里，我们穿着浴袍，结果连两个字都说不出来就笑场了，但这是一种非常自然的崩溃，每次看到它都让我感到无比快乐。
all the time. There was a ton of laughter on that show. I really, really loved it. Isn't that why we do what we do? I mean, yeah, those moments. I told you, I've said, I said this to David before and I want to say it's you just so you can hear, we've talked about it, but that the hardest I've ever laughed actually laughed in my
那个节目里有很多笑声。我真的，真的很喜欢它。这不就是我们为什么要从事这一行的原因吗？我是说，是的，就是那些时刻。我告诉你，我以前对大卫说过这话，我也想对你重申一遍，好让你能听到——我们讨论过这个——那就是我在我一生中，无论在哪里，不仅是在片场，而是在任何地方、任何时候，笑得最大声、真正开怀大笑的那一次，就是在那个场景里，本应是为露西尔做干预治疗，结果我们所有人都喝醉了，你穿着长袍在弹钢琴，大卫去拿了他的牛仔短裤穿上，在你旁边跳舞，我站在桌子上，杰森戴着假发，戴着富兰克林的假发，当时的感觉就是没有人说话，
life anywhere, this not just on set, just anywhere at any time was that scene where it was supposed to be an intervention for Lucille and we all end up getting drunk and you're on the piano with your hook and David went and got his, his jeans shorts and he put them and he's dancing next to you and I'm on the table and Jason's got the wig on. He's got Franklin's wig on and it was just like nobody said anything.
大家就像是彻底疯了一样。他们只是那种放飞自我的状态，那是一个星期五的深夜，我眼泪都笑出来了，而你当时正在，托尼在用力砸钢琴，就像巴斯特那么开心，大卫光着上身在他旁边跳舞。我在哭。我记得开车回家大约一个小时后，米奇打电话给我，当时我在车里，我接了电话，但我其实还在
It was just mayhem. They just sort of went like go mayhem and it was late on a Friday night and I had tears and you were just, and Tony was going, he's hammering on the piano like Buster's all happy and David's dancing next to him with no shirt on the thing. And I was crying. I remembered driving home and like an hour later, Mitch called me and I was in the car and I picked up, but I was still
一个人咯咯地笑个不停。太棒了。托尼，我是说，你们当时都在那儿，见证了我这辈子笑得最厉害的一次。噢，天哪。那真的，真的是太有趣了。不管怎样，嗨，肖恩。嗨。
actually laughing by myself. That's so good. Tony, I mean, you guys were there for the hardest laugh I've ever had. Oh man. That was so, so fun. Anyway, hi, Sean. Hi.
所以这剧的最佳播出时间是。在福克斯播，什么，周四？周日晚上8点，9点半。在Roku上收看。托尼，我们聊的时间太长了。已经5点45分了。这简直是给我们加了彩蛋。太疯狂了。
So the show's best development. It's on Fox, what, Thursday? Sundays at 8, 9.30. Catch you on Roku. Tony, this is way too much time. It's already 5.45. It's given us bonus. It's so crazy.
我们超时了。我们道歉。再次向我们的听众道歉，非常抱歉你们不得不听我们对托尼各种吹捧并聊起过去的旧时光，但我不知道。我太喜欢了。我们就是这么爱你。我们太爱他们了。
We went over. We apologize. And again, to our listener, I'm so sorry that we just, you had to hear us just farm all over Tony and talk about the old days, but I don't know. I loved it. We just love you so much. We just love them.
你们真的是最棒的。托尼，你是那种，你真的是一个不可思议的、不可思议的天才，你知道的，但，但更不用说的是，你是一个如此美妙、甜美、绝佳的好人。拥有一颗宽广的心。非常爱你。非常爱你，老兄。我也是。
You guys are the best. Tony, you're one of the, you're such an incredible, incredible talent and, you know, but, but even above and beyond that, you're such a wonderful, sweet, sweet, just great person. Big huge heart. Love you so much. Love you so much, man. Same.
请代我向马歇尔问好。我会的。我会的。我也爱你，托尼。谢谢你们。谢谢你，肖恩。我也爱你。希望能早点见到你。
Please say hi to Marshall. I will. I will. I love you too, Tony. Thank you guys. Thank you, Sean. I love you too. I'd love to see you soon.
我们找时间聚聚吧。好的。我们聚聚吧。嘿，伙计们。我们搞个重聚吧。搞个重聚特辑，对吧？《发展受阻》特辑。我可不想这么说。
Let's do it. All right. Let's do it. Hey guys. We'll do a reunion. Let's do it a reunion special, right? Arrested special. I don't want to say that.
我觉得我们就在这上面说吧。你们愿意吗？顺便说一句，我，为了《发展受阻》我什么都愿意做。你为什么不呢？随时愿意。你愿意吗，托尼？是的。
I think we just say that on the, would you guys do it? By the way, I'm just, I'd do anything for arrested. Why wouldn't you do that? Always. Would you do it, Tony? Yeah.
我明天就要回去那部剧工作了。是的，我也是。是的。肖恩，来吧。加入我们。嗨，米奇。希望你，希望你在听。托尼，爱你。
I go back to work tomorrow on that show. Yeah, me too. Yeah. Sean, come on. Come join us. Hi Mitch. Hope you're, hope you're listening. Tony, love you.
爱你，托尼。爱你们，伙计们。非常感谢。回头聊。谢谢你做这一切。谢谢你邀请我来。再见，老兄。再见，老兄。
Love you, Tony. Love you guys. Thank you very much. Talk to you soon. Thank you for doing this. Thank you for having me on. Bye, buddy. Bye, bud.
伙计们，抱歉。那是谁？那是谁？那是谁？杰伊，把托尼请来真是个绝佳的电话。是的。太棒了。我很爱那个家伙。
Guys, sorry. Who was that? Who was that? Who was that? Jay, that was such a great call having Tony. Yeah. That was great. I love that man.
再次声明，如果这听起来像是在我们自己的小俱乐部里自娱自乐，我向大家道歉。我知道。作为一个局外人旁观真的非常非常有趣。我能听到各种故事，甚至当时我都不在场。我一整天都能听这种故事，关于谁参与了，发生了什么。而且不管他说什么我都听得进去，
Again, I apologize if it was to our own little clubhouse, but. I know. It's really, really fun to be flying the wall. I could hear a story. I wasn't even there. And I could hear stories like that all day long, just about like who was on, what would happen. There's also anything that he says I can listen to,
因为他真的是太真诚了。我想我们在这个节目里经常这么说，但我认为你很难真正找到一个比他更好的人了。是的。在我们采访过的人里。我们采访过很多很好的人，但托尼真的是纯粹由美好的人格组成的。
because he truly is. He's so genuine. I think we say this a lot on this show, but I think you'd be hard pressed to really find truly a nicer person. Yeah. That we've interviewed. We've interviewed a lot of nice people, but Tony is just made of all good stuff.
我采访过他好几次，不像我代班主持艾伦，或者有一次主持吉米金梅尔的时候那样。但真的，我和他一起聚过好几次。他是那么真诚、甜美和友善。而且他非常搞笑。他总能逗我们笑，他自己也是个特别爽朗的笑匠，你真的很容易被他感染。
I've interviewed him a few times, unlike when I guest toasted like Ellen, or I think Kimmel once or something. But yeah, I've hung out with him a few times. So he's just so genuine and sweet and nice. And he was, he was so funny. He would make us laugh. And he was a great laugher and you could really get him.
我本来有一个非常棒的关于戏剧的故事想分享，但也许我下次再讲吧。说来听听吧。是不是关于你去为《再见，小鸟》试镜的那次？《再见，小鸟》。那挺好的。再见，小鸟。再见，伙计们。
I had a really good theater story to share, but maybe I'll do it next time. Let's hear it. Is it about the time that you got an audition for Bye Bye Birdie? Bye Bye Birdie. That's good. Bye Birdie. Bye guys.
再见。SmartLess是由罗布·阿姆贾尔、本·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里100%有机手工打造的。
Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjalf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry.
SmartLess。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Smart. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart. SmartLess. 本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。